If you would own... I could be a different version of your dad. I'm twice as funny and also twice as sad. I know just for not to say, but it's a game. Figures from our hand in hand and don't you frown. There's something like... Hey, guys, this is Joel with the Tapreet Therapy Collective Podcast, and we've been talking about the DSM and some of the things that are used to,
如果你拥有……我可以成为你父亲的另一个版本。我比他幽默两倍，也比他忧伤两倍。我知道有些话不该说，但这只是一场游戏。我们携手并进，别皱眉头。有些事情就像……嘿，大家好，我是Joel，这是Tapreet治疗集体播客，我们一直在讨论DSM以及一些被用来，
you know, guide psychotherapy, the history of how they got there and why those contradictions. assumptions at this point might not make any sense in mandatory structures that we have to participate in to continue to work and function. But I wanted to go back to something we talked about before, which is the Games People Play by John Nash. It's a book that's really interesting. I don't have anything against, I'm sorry, I said John Nash, the mathematician. I'm talking about Eric Byrne. The Games People Play is by Eric Byrne. I don't have anything John Nash will come up later. But like I don't have anything against burn. I don't think burn's a bad guy. Like the book, I use that. I'm not a transactional analyst, but I use that with patients sometimes to talk about
你知道，指导心理治疗的东西，它们是如何发展到这一步的历史，以及为什么这些矛盾。在这一点上，我们为了继续工作和运作而必须参与的强制性结构中的假设可能毫无意义。但我还是想回到我们之前讨论过的话题，即约翰·纳什的《博弈心理学》（Games People Play）。这是一本非常有趣的书。我没什么反对的，抱歉，我刚才说了约翰·纳什，那位数学家。我说的是埃里克·伯恩。《博弈心理学》的作者是埃里克·伯恩。我没什么反对的，约翰·纳什以后会提到。但我对伯恩没什么意见。我不觉得伯恩是个坏人。就像这本书，我用过它。我不是交互分析师，但我有时会用它和病人谈论
how to kind of manage and then anticipate the effects when we change systems. If you heal trauma in a marriage like in one person, the system of the marriage changes, you know, usually for the better, but sometimes there's just temporary instability where other things come to the surface that weren't there before because when you heal PTSD in one individual, you've now changed the game. And that is something that, you know, Byrne does well. So I'm not criticizing him. I'm just talking about I think he's an interesting and forgotten intersection point. I mean, and at one point he was one of the biggest authors in the world. I mean, the Eric Byrne, like, the things that we forget quickly sometimes are interesting to look at, like, why this book had the meteoric success that it did. Because it was
如何管理，以及当我们改变系统时如何预见其影响。如果你治愈了婚姻中的创伤，比如在一个人的身上，婚姻的系统就会改变，你知道，通常是向好的方向改变，但有时会有暂时的不稳定，因为以前不存在的其他东西会浮出水面，因为当你治愈了一个人的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），你就改变了这场游戏。这是伯恩做得很好的地方。所以我不是在批评他。我只是觉得他是一个有趣且被遗忘的交叉点。我的意思是，他曾经是世界上最伟大的作家之一。我是说，埃里克·伯恩，我们有时很快就会忘记的事情，看看它们是很有趣的，比如为什么这本书会取得如此巨大的成功。因为它在
really like on every coffee table by the late 60s. And there's still some people who remember it, but it's generally not something that people still use. As a therapy modality, it didn't really evolve into anything else. I mean, probably the most similar thing to it would be like coherence therapy. But I don't think it's as interesting clinically. That's not my point.
60年代末真的出现在每个人的咖啡桌上。现在还有一些人记得它，但它通常不再是人们使用的东西了。作为一种治疗模式，它并没有真正演变成其他东西。我的意思是，可能最相似的东西是相干疗法（Coherence Therapy）。但我不认为它在临床上那么有趣。这不是我的重点。
My point is that transactional analysis, which is the modality that Byrne would create with his book games, people play, interesting intersection point in history. It gives you like all of these things where stuff was starting to go off the rails with therapy in the 70s and then overcorrected in the 80s. We talked about that in the weird history of psychotherapy series. So let's start.
我的重点是，交互分析，也就是伯恩通过他的书《博弈心理学》所创造的模式，是历史上一个有趣的交叉点。它让你看到所有这些事情，70年代治疗开始失控，然后在80年代过度矫正。我们在“心理治疗的怪异历史”系列中讨论过这一点。所以让我们开始吧。
You know, John Nash, who's the guy that you probably know from A Beautiful Mind, the movie with Russell Crow, plays the kind of genius mathematician who struggles with schizophrenia. But what the movie doesn't quite convey is that Nash was actually like working on this theory that they underplay the importance of in the movie. They just act like this was really useful. Nobody else had realized it. Now he gets the Nobel Prize. But that theory changed a lot of things that people don't,
你知道，约翰·纳什，就是你可能从罗素·克劳主演的电影《美丽心灵》中认识的那个人，他扮演的是那种与精神分裂症作斗争的天才数学家。但电影没有完全传达的是，纳什实际上是在研究这个理论，而电影中淡化了它的重要性。他们只是表现得好像这真的很有用。没有其他人意识到这一点。现在他获得了诺贝尔奖。但那个理论改变了很多人们没有意识到的事情，
and that movie does a poor job of explaining how Nash's theories were used. Nash was a Rand Corporation. He worked at Rand Corporation during the Cold War, and Rand is a think, or was and still is a think tank that's funded by U.S. military to develop strategies for nuclear confrontation with the Soviets. That's not as much of what they do now. But at the time, you know, it's this kind of libertarian-leading think-take. And they question that they were trying to answer with Nash's work is,
而且那部电影在解释纳什的理论是如何被使用方面做得并不好。纳什在冷战期间曾在兰德公司工作，兰德是一个智库，或者曾经是，现在仍然是，由美国军方资助，旨在制定与苏联进行核对抗的战略。他们现在做的事情没那么多了。但在当时，你知道，这是一种倾向于自由意志主义的智库。他们试图用纳什的工作来回答的问题是，
how do you predict what your enemy will do when you can't trust them? Because it's kind of like you get quantum physics when you take classical physics to its extremes. And you say like, what if all of gravity is so high that things condensed down into one atom? and what happens when, you know, all of a sudden, like, you surpass the speed of light and all these things that you kind of can't do and then the math takes you into this another thing. When you start talking about how to win chess, it's like the goal is to win chess, but when you're talking about a game that is like, what if we can kill everybody on Earth a hundred times over with the amount of nuclear weapons we have and how do we predict how someone will act with that information, then the game intersects with psychology in this way where all of a sudden you're getting into the predictive output. algorithms that run the human mind because it isn't a quote unquote logical or objective way that you can plan to conduct or prevent a nuclear war. You know, it's it's such a mind-boggling thought experiment. I think a lot of people don't even remember that we had that potential.
当你无法信任敌人时，你如何预测他们会做什么？因为这有点像当你把经典物理学推向极端时，你就会得到量子物理学。你说，如果所有的引力都那么大，以至于物质浓缩成一个原子会怎样？当你突然超过光速，所有这些你做不到的事情发生时，数学会把你带向另一个领域。当你开始谈论如何赢得国际象棋时，目标是赢得比赛，但当你谈论的是一种游戏，比如，如果我们拥有的核武器数量足以杀死地球上所有人一百次，我们该如何预测某人会根据这些信息采取什么行动，那么这场游戏就会以这种方式与心理学交叉，突然之间，你进入了运行人类思维的预测算法，因为你无法以一种所谓的逻辑或客观的方式来计划进行或预防核战争。你知道，这真是一个令人难以置信的思想实验。我想很多人甚至不记得我们曾经拥有那种潜力。
Developed in the 60s like in somebody's lifetime, the worst you could do is like, I don't know, blow up a building or start a war. and then all of a sudden it became that this imperative to figure out how to manage these things that could end on life on earth, and that's this huge psychological burden. So not to talk about the Cold War too much, but Nash develops game theory, which is the Cold War's why it's relevant. It was just this mathematical model for strategic decision-making in competitive situations. So there's, you know, the prisoner's dilemma that Adam Curtis talks about in his movie is kind of what Nash's thing was based on.
在60年代发展起来，在某人的一生中，你能做的最坏的事情就是，我不知道，炸毁一栋建筑或发动一场战争。然后突然之间，这就变成了一种必须弄清楚如何管理这些可能终结地球生命的东西的迫切需求，这是一种巨大的心理负担。所以不是要过多谈论冷战，但纳什发展了博弈论，这就是冷战为什么与之相关的原因。它只是竞争情况下战略决策的数学模型。所以，你知道，亚当·柯蒂斯在他的电影中谈到的囚徒困境，就是纳什理论的基础。
And in the movie, a beautiful mind, what he does is he says, hey, we all want to take home the girl at the bar in the red dress who's the prettiest, and that would be the most obvious course of action would be all of us to go ask for that girl. But if we do that, then all of us kind of will lose. But if we all go to all of her friends,
在电影《美丽心灵》中，他所做的是，他说，嘿，我们都想带走酒吧里那个穿红裙子的女孩，她是最好看的，最明显的做法是我们都去邀请那个女孩。但如果我们那样做，我们所有人都会输。但如果我们都去找她的朋友们，
friends, she's confused and they're flattered and so we would win. And so there's this kind of, we don't actually want to even take home the person we're taking home, but there's this self-interest in us playing the game this way where we all get what we want, that the screenwriter's trying to get across. I don't think that there was a girl in a bar that led up to that realization for Nash. I think it was more of these kind of thought experiments. But when a filmmaker, Adam Curtis that I talk about a lot, a documentarian, when he introduces Nash and his kind of effect on the greater culture, one of the things that he uses to explain it is this thing called the Prisoners Delimmy gets used a lot. Adam Curtis has this story about a jewel thief and a gangster.
朋友们，她会感到困惑，而她们会受宠若惊，所以我们会赢。所以有这样一种，我们甚至不想带走我们正在带走的那个人，但我们以这种方式玩游戏存在一种自身利益，我们都能得到我们想要的，这是编剧试图表达的。我不认为酒吧里有一个女孩导致了纳什的那个认识。我认为这更多是那种思想实验。但当一位电影制作人，我经常谈到的纪录片导演亚当·柯蒂斯，介绍纳什及其对更广泛文化的影响时，他用来解释这一点的事情之一就是所谓的囚徒困境，它被广泛使用。亚当·柯蒂斯有一个关于珠宝大盗和黑帮的故事。
And he says, you know, you've stolen this rare diamond and there's a gangster that wants to buy it from you, but you're both criminals so you don't trust each other. So John Nash's theory is about when two parties have conflicting interests, they can't trust each other. And they're not. other. How do they win? You know, that was his contribution. So, um, the gangster could just shoot you and take the diamond if you meet in person. So you agree to a remote swap where you'll hide the diamond in a field and he will hide the cash in a different field and then you'll call each other, you'll reveal the location and you'll go get it. So if you tell him the true location, what if he lies to you? And then he goes off and gets the diamond and he keeps the money and he
他说，你知道，你偷了一颗稀有钻石，有一个黑帮想从你这里买走，但你们都是罪犯，所以你们互不信任。所以约翰·纳什的理论是关于当双方有冲突的利益时，他们无法信任对方。他们不是。对方。他们如何获胜？你知道，这就是他的贡献。所以，嗯，如果你亲自见面，黑帮可以直接开枪打死你并拿走钻石。所以你们同意进行远程交换，你把钻石藏在一个田野里，他把现金藏在另一个田野里，然后你们互相打电话，揭露位置，然后你们去取。所以如果你告诉他真实位置，如果他骗你怎么办？然后他去拿了钻石，留下了钱，他
leaves you with nothing. And then if you lie to him, he tells you the truth, you get the money and you get to keep the diamond. So because you're both right, rational, self-interested and suspicious, you know, which is Nash's view of humanity, you both lie, and you keep the diamond. And then he keeps the money. And then the deal, which would have benefited both of you, never happens. So Curtis is showing you that to show that Nash developed these theories that were basically, you know, paranoia. He was saying that, you know, before Nash, if you look at the history of game theory, it's von Neumann, who's like the big guy. And von Neumann's theories are all about one point.
让你一无所有。然后如果你骗他，他告诉你真相，你得到了钱，你还能保留钻石。所以因为你们俩都是理性的、自私的、多疑的（这就是纳什对人性的看法），你们俩都撒谎，你留下了钻石。然后他留下了钱。然后那笔本可以使你们双方受益的交易，永远不会发生。所以柯蒂斯向你展示这一点是为了说明纳什发展的这些理论基本上是，你知道，偏执。他说，你知道，在纳什之前，如果你看博弈论的历史，那是冯·诺依曼，他是大人物。冯·诺依曼的理论都是关于一点。
party has to win, so what do they do? And John Nash's contribution that gets picked up by the DoD during the Cold War is what if they don't actually want to win? What if they just want to get the best outcome for themselves, and that is the win condition? So they don't not necessarily, they don't want the other party to lose. Maybe they do, but you don't know that. There are situations where people can get self-interest with neither party losing. And so that leads to, this assumption that mutually assured destruction is actually a good thing. Instead of trying to stop proliferation and conquer all these Soviet countries or Soviet influence countries and move missile silos around, we should just go ahead and let them
一方必须赢，那么他们该怎么做？而约翰·纳什在冷战期间被国防部采纳的贡献是，如果他们实际上不想赢怎么办？如果他们只是想为自己获得最好的结果，而那就是获胜条件呢？所以他们不一定，他们不希望对方输。也许他们希望，但你不知道。在某些情况下，人们可以在双方都不输的情况下获得自身利益。这导致了这种假设，即相互保证毁灭实际上是一件好事。与其试图阻止核扩散并征服所有这些苏联国家或受苏联影响的国家并移动导弹发射井，我们不如直接让他们
build them and then build our own. And both countries will sink billions of dollars into this stalemate. But the stalemate will actually keep us safe because the wind condition is survival. And if anybody shoots, everybody dies. You know, risky game, right, to ride on a theory. But that's essentially how it was used. Now, I want to add that later, you know, we have that that it wasn't really real. It wasn't what was happening.
建造它们，然后建造我们自己的。两国都将投入数十亿美元在这个僵局中。但这个僵局实际上会让我们保持安全，因为获胜条件是生存。如果有人开火，所有人都会死。你知道，这是一场冒险的游戏，对吧，建立在一个理论之上？但这就是它被使用的方式。现在，我想补充一点，后来，你知道，我们有那个，它并不是真的。那不是正在发生的事情。
People kept feeding to the DoD that all the Soviets were building all these missiles that historically we know they weren't really building. We had something insane like 20 something times the amount of nukes that the Soviet had at their height, you know, the USSR. are. But we assumed that because this was the way that you predict other people's behavior, that this was the thing that was going to keep us safe, and it was the assumption that everybody is acting on. And so, you know, what Curtis is pointing out is to make the math work, Nash had to make this assumption. He had to assume that human beings are isolated, suspicious, and purely self-interested agents. They were just machines basically programmed to do the ideological imperative of self-interest.
人们不断向国防部提供信息，说苏联正在建造所有这些导弹，而从历史上看我们知道他们并没有真正建造。在苏联鼎盛时期，我们拥有的核武器数量是苏联的20多倍，你知道，苏联。但是我们假设，因为这是预测他人行为的方式，这就是让我们保持安全的东西，而且这是每个人都在采取行动的假设。所以，你知道，柯蒂斯指出的是，为了让数学成立，纳什必须做出这个假设。他必须假设人类是孤立的、多疑的、纯粹自私的代理人。他们基本上只是被编程来执行自私的意识形态命令的机器。
And in Nash's models, we're always strategizing to betray the other person before they betray us. But here's the thing. Curtis emphasizes Nash was suffering from paranoid schizophrenia at the time. There's like a really funny clip in that movie where John Nash is being asked by Curtis about if he thinks that they did the right thing by listening to him. And Nash, who's known for his theories because he came up with them. And won the Nobel Prize is like, hell no, nobody should have listened to me. I thought that everybody who had a red tie on was a Soviet agent. and I believed in aliens were talking to me. Like, I had paranoid schizophrenia, and they gave me a Nobel Prize,
在纳什的模型中，我们总是策划在对方背叛我们之前背叛对方。但问题是。柯蒂斯强调，纳什当时患有偏执型精神分裂症。那部电影里有一个非常有趣的片段，柯蒂斯问约翰·纳什，他是否认为他们听从他是正确的做法。而以他的理论闻名并获得诺贝尔奖的纳什说，去他的，没人应该听我的。我以为每个系红领带的人都是苏联特工。而且我相信外星人在跟我说话。就像，我患有偏执型精神分裂症，而他们给了我一个诺贝尔奖，
which was towards the ends of Nash's life. It was kind of an interesting scene. He doesn't get shown that way that much. But he was literally paranoid. He believed people were following him around. He saw patterns and conspiracies everywhere. He's hospitalized multiple times and just kind of allowed to live on Harvard's campus as like a dude.
这是在纳什生命的最后阶段。这是一个有趣的场景。他没有被那样展示太多。但他确实是偏执的。他相信有人在跟踪他。他到处都能看到模式和阴谋。他多次住院，只是被允许像个普通人一样住在哈佛校园里。
And Curtis argues that Nash projected his own paranoid view of the world into his mathematical model. And the model assumes that everyone thinks the way Nash thought when he was in this grip of illness. They're suspicious. They're calculating. They're always looking to betray. And the military loves it, you know, and they're trying to model the Soviets paranoia on, they're trying to model the Soviets paranoia in their own defense, in their own game.
柯蒂斯认为，纳什将他自己偏执的世界观投射到了他的数学模型中。该模型假设每个人都像纳什在疾病发作时那样思考。他们多疑、精于算计、总是寻求背叛。军方喜欢它，你知道，他们试图在自己的防御、自己的游戏中模拟苏联的偏执。
But the paranoia is completely projected, you know. And here's the thing that is discovered when they actually test Nash's model on real human. It breaks down every time. In the prisoner's dilemma, they did variations of this experiment where you can sell your cellmate out to get a lesser sentence, but if y'all both benefiting means that you don't sell him out, but it's always the best condition for you to go ahead and, you know, betray the other person. So in those different variations where they tested that experiment on real people, people trusted each other when they shouldn't have done it. And they gave wealth away and they cooperated and they acted from. not spite or, you know, but this intuition and loyalty.
但这种偏执完全是投射出来的，你知道。这就是当他们真正用真人测试纳什的模型时发现的事情。它每次都会崩溃。在囚徒困境中，他们做了这个实验的变体，你可以出卖你的狱友以获得较轻的刑期，但如果你们俩都受益意味着你不卖掉他，但对你来说，继续，你知道，背叛对方总是最好的条件。所以在那些测试真人实验的不同变体中，人们在不该信任的时候信任了对方。他们放弃了财富，他们合作，他们采取行动不是出于恶意，或者，你知道，而是出于直觉和忠诚。
And in other words, they acted human, right? And even under lab conditions, with real stakes, Nash's elegant predictions failed to predict actual human behavior ever. And the failure wasn't a fluke. It was this flashing red light that the human mind is not a machine built for logic. But our civilization continued to assume that from that point onward, which is why I think Byrne is interesting because it's when those ideas come into psychotherapy. You know, we're not spreadsheets or algorithms.
换句话说，他们表现得像人，对吧？即使在实验室条件下，在有真实赌注的情况下，纳什优雅的预测也从未能预测到实际的人类行为。这种失败不是侥幸。这是一个闪烁的红灯，表明人类思维不是为逻辑而构建的机器。但我们的文明从那时起继续做出这种假设，这就是为什么我认为伯恩很有趣，因为那是这些想法进入心理治疗的时候。你知道，我们不是电子表格或算法。
We're narrative-making grief-haunted, hope-driven, embodied animals. And the models didn't stay in the war rooms, and nobody paid attention to the fact that this stuff that we were basing billions of dollars in our whole culture on was not really right with psychology. We were forcing people to fit the model, not building a model to fit the person. And here's what happened with game theory worldwide. It starts leaking into the broader culture, and so economists pick it up. And if humans are rational, self-interested agents, then you can model markets as games.
我们是叙事制造的、被悲伤困扰的、被希望驱动的、具身化的动物。这些模型并没有留在作战室里，也没有人注意到这样一个事实，即我们赖以建立数十亿美元和整个文化的东西在心理学上并不真正正确。我们是在强迫人们适应模型，而不是建立一个适应人的模型。这就是博弈论在全世界发生的事情。它开始渗入更广泛的文化，所以经济学家采纳了它。如果人类是理性的、自私的代理人，那么你就可以把市场建模为游戏。
You can predict behavior. You can design incentive structures. Psychologists picked it up. If humans are strategic actors seeking payoffs, then relationships are just transactions. You know, you can analyze social interaction the same way that you can analyze a chess game. And then in 1964, Eric Byrne publishes the games people play. Now, like, you have Freudian psychoanalysis in the water. And then you have game theory coming in in the culture.
你可以预测行为。你可以设计激励结构。心理学家采纳了它。如果人类是寻求回报的战略参与者，那么关系就只是交易。你知道，你可以像分析国际象棋比赛一样分析社会互动。然后在1964年，埃里克·伯恩出版了《博弈心理学》。现在，就像，你有弗洛伊德的精神分析在潜移默化中。然后你有博弈论进入文化中。
And that's why the games people play is written. I mean, I don't know that he ever says, Eric Byrne ever says I made this book because of John Nash, but you have to understand, you know, the height of these things in the 60s that were just getting so big and written about it was the lens that everybody saw the world. Like, of course that's what happened. And they emerged from this zeitgeist
这就是《博弈心理学》被写出来的原因。我的意思是，我不知道他是否曾经说过，埃里克·伯恩是否曾经说过我写这本书是因为约翰·纳什，但你必须明白，你知道，这些东西在60年代的高度，它们变得如此之大并被书写，它是每个人看待世界的镜头。就像，当然发生了那种事。它们源于这种时代精神，
of the same Cold War paranoia and the same suspicion that underneath all our noble talks about love and duty were really just manipulating each other. You know, and Byrne gives this, this vocationationation. He gave it to the public. And Burns' book taught millions of readers that our social lives are not driven by love or duty or authenticity. They're driven by hidden strategies and payoffs. He calls them strokes.
同样的冷战偏执和同样的怀疑，即在我们所有关于爱和责任的高尚谈话之下，我们实际上只是在操纵彼此。你知道，伯恩给了这个，这个职业化。他把它给了公众。伯恩的书教导了数百万读者，我们的社交生活不是由爱、责任或真实性驱动的。它们是由隐藏的策略和回报驱动的。他称它们为“抚摸”（strokes）。
We're all just playing games. We want to get emotional leverage. And what I think Burns' book is good and it works is it tells you how you can see things that people, you know, and they may not even be aware of it, you know, unconsciously or motivated by based in the way that they act, that you can sort of see. unconscious with an objective variable of a game. That's kind of why it works to help predict how somebody will do something and the way that you can best address that when it comes up. It's a great book for boundaries with families and different things like that. But there is this assumption that it is kind of taken to mean where psychiatry,
我们都只是在玩游戏。我们想要获得情感杠杆。我认为伯恩的书很好，它有效的地方在于它告诉你如何看待人们，你知道，他们甚至可能没有意识到这一点，你知道，无意识地或基于他们行为方式的动机，你可以某种程度上看到。带有游戏客观变量的无意识。这就是为什么它有助于预测某人会如何做某事，以及当它出现时你最好如何处理它的原因。这是一本关于家庭界限和类似不同事情的好书。但有一种假设，它被认为意味着精神病学，
clinical psychology, the broader psychology sort of becomes cynical. It's not about really understanding yourself and healing something and going back in. it's about understanding how you can control other people by predicting their mind and see through them to really understand what they're doing so that you can get what you want. Byrne doesn't do that at all. I'm not criticizing Byrne. I'm talking about how a book like that is going to be picked up by a culture that is paranoid, and it was. You know, and here's what Byrne introduced that would have the later enormous implications. He argued that human beings have this fundamental need for what he calls strokes. A stroke is any form of recognition, so it can be positive or negative.
临床心理学，更广泛的心理学变得愤世嫉俗。这不是关于真正了解自己并治愈某事并回到内心。它是关于了解你如何通过预测他人的思想来控制他们，并看穿他们以真正了解他们在做什么，这样你就可以得到你想要的。伯恩根本没有那样做。我不是在批评伯恩。我是在谈论像这样的书是如何被一个偏执的文化所采纳的，而且确实如此。你知道，这是伯恩引入的后来产生巨大影响的东西。他认为人类有一种对所谓“抚摸”的基本需求。抚摸是任何形式的认可，所以它可以是积极的或消极的。
and a compliment or an insult when we need it, our nervous system, you know, it requires this simulation, or yeah, this stimulation from relational energy. And if you get only positive strokes, you'll manipulate situations, I'm sorry, if you don't get your positive strokes, like if you don't get the positive thing, you'll manipulate situations to get negative strokes. You'll have your inner narrative, you'll manipulate your environment to fulfill your inner narrative so that you get the relationship to the world that you want. If it doesn't, doesn't just give it to you directly. And you're not even aware a lot of the time how you're being passive, aggressive,
当我们需要它时，一个赞美或一个侮辱，我们的神经系统，你知道，它需要这种模拟，或者是的，这种来自关系能量的刺激。如果你只得到积极的抚摸，你就会操纵情况，抱歉，如果你没有得到你的积极抚摸，比如如果你没有得到积极的东西，你就会操纵情况来获得消极的抚摸。你会有你的内在叙事，你会操纵你的环境来满足你的内在叙事，这样你就能得到你想要的与世界的关系。如果它没有，没有直接给你。而且你很多时候甚至没有意识到你是如何被动、攻击性的，
or being manipulative there. A lot of times we hide that from ourselves. So an abused child learns that provoking punishment is better than being ignored. This is the only way that I can have attention, so I'll settle for the negative attention. And then Byrne is saying basically that we're all abused children. And, you know, or all the people playing games at least that aren't in the adult ego state. They were even in the parentified or the child ego state. And thus a game is possible.
或者在那里表现得具有操纵性。很多时候我们对自己隐藏了这一点。所以一个受虐待的孩子学会了挑衅惩罚比被忽视要好。这是我能得到关注的唯一方式，所以我将满足于消极的关注。然后伯恩基本上是在说我们都是受虐待的孩子。而且，你知道，或者至少所有玩游戏的人都不在成人自我状态。他们甚至在父母化或儿童自我状态。因此，游戏是可能的。
Anyone acting in the adult ego state who's aware of their behavior cannot be a part of a game. So when you get somebody to the adult ego state in therapy, then it breaks the games. And the other person has to change. And this is why people play games. Games are stroke-seeking behaviors. You know, even destructive games, games that make everyone miserable, they persist because they reliably produce the reward. Do you see what's happening here? You know, Byrne has taken human connection, love, recognition, the stuff that makes life meaningful.
任何处于成人自我状态并意识到自己行为的人都不可能参与游戏。所以当你在治疗中让某人进入成人自我状态时，它就会打破游戏。而另一个人必须改变。这就是为什么人们玩游戏。游戏是寻求抚摸的行为。你知道，即使是破坏性的游戏，让每个人都痛苦的游戏，它们之所以持续存在，是因为它们可靠地产生了奖励。你看到这里发生了什么吗？你知道，伯恩已经把人类的联系、爱、认可，这些让生活有意义的东西，
And I don't think he did this as a person. I think he was an interesting guy. But he's given society this lens to see psychology as a tool that can reconceptualize, you know, its goal as getting currency, as not about treating the individual like a medicine, you know. It's about using psychology in order to get what you want out of others. You know, this is a pretty obvious connection that a world like this is going to draw. And this isn't quite the same as national. game theory where everyone is a cold rational calculator. Burns games are about unconscious driven needs that we don't understand.
我不认为他作为一个人的时候是这样做的。我认为他是一个有趣的人。但他给了社会这个镜头，将心理学视为一种可以重新概念化，你知道，其目标是获得货币的工具，而不是像药物一样对待个人，你知道。它是关于使用心理学以从他人那里得到你想要的。你知道，这是一个非常明显的联系，像这样的世界会得出这个结论。这与纳什的博弈论不完全一样，每个人都是冷酷的理性计算器。伯恩的游戏是关于我们不了解的无意识驱动的需求。
But the frame and the metaphor uses the same assumption as Nash's that even if you're being nice, you're just doing it because you're self-interested, right? And, you know, Byrne would say, unless you're in the adult ego state and then you're well, but society doesn't grasp that point. You know, there's a philosopher that I like, Ty Nugian, and he's done the best contemporary work on what games actually are and why the game metaphor is so dangerous when it escapes its proper domain. Nugent draws a distinction between the purpose and the point of a game.
但它使用的框架和隐喻与纳什的假设相同，即即使你表现得很好，你也只是因为你自私才这样做，对吧？而且，你知道，伯恩会说，除非你处于成人自我状态，然后你很好，但社会没有抓住那个点。你知道，有一位我喜欢的哲学家，Ty Nugian，他做了关于游戏实际上是什么，以及为什么游戏隐喻在逃离其适当领域时如此危险的最佳当代工作。纽金区分了游戏的目的（purpose）和意义（point）。
So the purpose of the game is the explicit goal. It's the wind condition. It's chess. It's a checkmate in a monopoly. It's banking. You're bankrupting your opponent. In a video game, it's beating the final boss or getting the most points, whatever. And the purpose is built into the structure of the game itself.
所以游戏的目的（purpose）是明确的目标。它是获胜条件。它是国际象棋。它是大富翁里的将死。它是银行业。你正在让你的对手破产。在电子游戏中，它是打败最终boss或获得最高分，等等。而目的（purpose）是内置在游戏本身的结构中的。
But the point of a game is different from the purpose. it's the deeper reason that you play. So why do you play chess? Not really to checkmate your opponent. You play for the sense of mastery, for the beauty of strategy, for the challenge, and for the connection with the person across the board,
但游戏的意义（point）不同于目的（purpose）。它是你玩游戏的更深层原因。所以你为什么玩国际象棋？并不是真的为了将死你的对手。你玩是为了掌握感，为了策略的美感，为了挑战，以及为了与棋盘对面的人的联系，
for the flow state, and for the hidden insights that you never would have pulled out of yourself if it wasn't for the game putting you in the situation where you were challenged to come up with them. And the purpose is what the game tells you to want, but the point is what you actually want.
为了心流状态，以及为了那些如果不是因为游戏让你处于被挑战想出它们的境地，你永远不会从自己身上挖掘出来的隐藏洞察力。而目的（purpose）是游戏告诉你想要的东西，但意义（point）是你真正想要的东西。
And good games align these. So the pursuit of the purpose delivers the point. You chase checkmate, and in chasing it, you experience mastery. And the goal serves the meaning. But here's what happens when the game loses its logic. It escapes into domains where it doesn't belong. So the purpose replaces the point. So in health care, the purpose becomes this metric.
好的游戏会使这些保持一致。所以对目的（purpose）的追求传递了意义（point）。你追逐将死，在追逐的过程中，你体验到了掌握感。而目标服务于意义。但当游戏失去逻辑时会发生什么？它逃逸到它不属于的领域。所以目的（purpose）取代了意义（point）。所以在医疗保健中，目的（purpose）变成了这个指标。
The RVU, the patient satisfaction score, the depression questionnaire number, the purpose is measurable, auditable, optimizable. the point was healing at the beginning, and then later the point it becomes competition. So when you gamify healthcare, especially psychology, you optimize for the purpose and you destroy the point. So doctors learn to game the metrics. You're essentially teaching the test.
RVU（相对价值单位）、患者满意度评分、抑郁症问卷数字，目的（purpose）是可衡量的、可审计的、可优化的。意义（point）在开始时是治愈，后来意义（point）变成了竞争。所以当你游戏化医疗保健，尤其是心理学时，你优化了目的（purpose）并摧毁了意义（point）。所以医生学会了操纵指标。你本质上是在教学生如何应付考试。
And they do what gets measured. But the unmeasured stuff that actually matters, it withers. And this is what Burns' framework did to, I think the broader culture. I think that a lot of people started to see psychology as this thing that they could sort of use to corrupt and manipulate and understand. I mean, the DOD is starting to use
他们做的是被衡量的事情。但那些未被衡量但实际上重要的事情，却枯萎了。这就是伯恩的框架对，我认为更广泛的文化所做的事情。我认为很多人开始将心理学视为一种他们可以用来腐蚀、操纵和理解的东西。我的意思是，国防部开始使用
where game theory is bumping up against psychology. So, you know, games people play tells the culture authenticity is basically a myth. If everyone's playing games, then the person who claims to be authentic is just playing a more sophisticated game than you. And the public servant who says they want to help people, they're playing a game to increase their status and their budget.
博弈论与心理学碰撞的地方。所以，你知道，《博弈心理学》告诉文化，真实性基本上是一个神话。如果每个人都在玩游戏，那么声称自己真实的人只是在玩比你更复杂的游戏。而声称想帮助人们的公务员，他们正在玩游戏以提高他们的地位和预算。
It puts you in competition with everybody, even the politician that represents you. You know, the spouse who says that they love you, they're really playing a game to get strokes. And the therapists who claims to care, they're playing a game to feel important to avoid their inner child that's really hurting and projected on you or to get paid or whatever. And nothing is what it seems. Everybody has this angle. Trust is for suckers. It becomes this paranoid world. I think that's why this book got so big at the time that it did, where American psychology and the broader culture is very paranoid. This is the,
它让你与每个人竞争，甚至是代表你的政客。你知道，声称爱你的配偶，他们实际上是在玩游戏以获得抚摸。而声称关心的治疗师，他们正在玩游戏以感到重要，以避免他们内心真正受伤并投射到你身上的内在小孩，或者为了赚钱等等。没有什么看起来是那样的。每个人都有这个角度。信任是给傻瓜的。它变成了这个偏执的世界。我认为这就是为什么这本书在当时变得如此之大，当时美国心理学和更广泛的文化非常偏执。这是，
because this is during the crisis of faith in the entire thing, right? Like this is before, you know, psychology is revision to be this scientific pursuit, and a lot of people already kind of think that it's bunk. And this is that same conclusion that Nash's math reach. It just is expressed in psychological language. And once this view became common sense, everyone knew that social life was just this strategic,
因为这是在对整个事情的信仰危机期间，对吧？就像这是在，你知道，心理学被修正为这种科学追求之前，而且很多人已经认为它是胡说八道。这就是纳什的数学达到的那个相同的结论。它只是用心理学语言表达出来的。一旦这种观点成为常识，每个人都知道社交生活只是这种战略性的、
manipulation, something, you know, important, collapsed. You know, and when you take that in a vacuum, because I think what starts in the mid-60s gets magnified up until it kind of reaches its zenith in the middle of the 80s, I mean, what you get is something like American Psycho, right? That idea of that kind of person, that you showing your business card to somebody and them acting curious about it is actually this battle with swords where you want to kill them and burn their house and take their property that's taking place at the office. It kind of enters American culture there.
操纵，某事，你知道，重要的东西崩溃了。你知道，当你把它放在真空中时，因为我认为从60年代中期开始的东西被放大，直到它在80年代中期达到顶峰，我的意思是，你得到的是像《美国精神病人》这样的东西，对吧？那种人的想法，你向某人展示你的名片，他们表现出好奇，实际上这是一场你想要杀死他们、烧毁他们的房子并夺取他们财产的剑战，发生在办公室里。它在那里进入了美国文化。
And so these old models of society, the ones that have been based on collectivism, collective trust, relationship, duty, tradition, public service, moral obligation, trying to be a better version of your dad. You know, like that, they started looking like hypocritical lies. And they were just the games that were played by people who were trying to control you. and so that sets you up for, you know, in the 1960s and the 70s, this group of economists developed something called public choice theory. And the idea is really simple. Let's apply game theory to politics.
所以这些旧的社会模型，那些基于集体主义、集体信任、关系、责任、传统、公共服务、道德义务、试图成为你父亲的更好版本的模型。你知道，像那样，它们开始看起来像虚伪的谎言。它们只是那些试图控制你的人玩的游戏。所以这为你设置了，你知道，在1960年代和70年代，这群经济学家发展了一种叫做公共选择理论的东西。这个想法真的很简单。让我们把博弈论应用到政治上。
Let's assume that politicians, bureaucrats, and public servants are the same self-interested rational agents that Nash's model describes. They're not serving the public good. They're maximizing their own utility, getting rich on the public dollar. You know, these public servants have never worked a day in their life except at their public service job that they work at. And the politician isn't trying to help constituents. They're just trying to get reelected. And the bureaucrat isn't trying to serve citizens. They're just trying to expand their budget and their power.
让我们假设政客、官僚和公务员是纳什模型所描述的相同的自私的理性代理人。他们不是在服务公共利益。他们是在最大化自己的效用，用公共资金致富。你知道，这些公务员除了在他们工作的公共服务岗位上工作外，从来没有工作过一天。而政客并不是在试图帮助选民。他们只是在试图连任。而官僚并不是在试图服务公民。他们只是在试图扩大他们的预算和权力。
And the teacher isn't trying to educate children. They're trying to minimize effort, maximize job security, and then inject their own politics slash religion into your kids. And the doctor isn't trying to heal patients. They're trying to maximize their income. And the social workers are not trying to help you. to get information on you from the government. There's a paranoia that you start to see in psychosis that was never there before that really picks up around 1960s and then is magnified all the way through the 80s where psychotic episodes
而老师并不是在试图教育孩子。他们是在试图最小化努力，最大化工作保障，然后把他们自己的政治/宗教注入你的孩子。而医生并不是在试图治愈病人。他们是在试图最大化他们的收入。而社会工作者并不是在试图帮助你。从政府那里获取关于你的信息。你在精神病中开始看到一种以前从未有过的偏执，在1960年代左右真正兴起，然后一直放大到80年代，那时精神病发作
have this paranoia about initially surveillance and government and control. And then as you start to get computers by the mid-70s and then the awareness of computers gets bigger, all of that, you know, people who are going psychotic, who are in the collective unconscious or talking about how computers are being used to control and manipulate them. There's a scene that never really made a lot of sense to me in the show Mad Men, where when they get a computer, one of the people who kind of has latent schizophrenia that's like going through the prodromal period, I think it's like implied that his dad also had a dopamine disorder. So good job, Matt Werner, you got one right. We have, you know, something on psychology that is
对最初的监视、政府和控制有这种偏执。然后当你到70年代中期开始有计算机，然后对计算机的意识变得更大时，所有这些，你知道，那些精神病发作的人，那些在集体无意识中或谈论计算机如何被用来控制和操纵他们的人。在电视剧《广告狂人》中有一个场景，对我来说从来没有太大的意义，当他们得到一台计算机时，其中一个患有潜在精神分裂症的人，正在经历前驱期，我想暗示他的父亲也有多巴胺紊乱。所以干得好，马特·韦纳，你做对了一件事。我们有，你知道，关于心理学的东西是
accurate on television. I was watching The Pit yesterday. And season two, is not really much better. Like, they are still, their knowledge of social work and psychology and hospitals is that they exist. So pretty much like what a lot of doctors, I guess,
在电视上准确的。我昨天在看《The Pit》。第二季，其实也没好多少。就像，他们仍然，他们对社会工作、心理学和医院的知识就是它们存在。所以很像很多医生，我想，
who are the medical advisors, know about them. I don't want to digress too much in these, but man, in the first episode of season two of the pit, no spoilers for anything important, but there's a lady that comes in and she's smiling a lot and she's like,
作为医学顾问，对它们了解的情况。我不想在这些方面跑题太多，但是天哪，在《The Pit》第二季的第一集里，对任何重要的事情都没有剧透，但有一个女士进来了，她笑得很开心，她说，
I'm so happy today and I'm 75. And they're like, oh, we see you all the day. time for your heart. Why are you so happy? And she was like, I ate a bunch of weed cookies from my friend's short store. They bought them at a CBD store because they got to talk about contemporary issues and like weed being semi-legal or whatever in the show to be topical. And they're like, oh, well, you know, marijuana is a drug and you should be careful even if it is legal, ma'am. How many did you eat? And she's like, oh, I ate nine or ten. And I'm just, I'm smiling so much.
我今天太开心了，我75岁了。他们说，哦，我们整天都看到你。该吃药了。你为什么这么开心？她说，我吃了一堆我朋友短店里的杂草饼干。他们在CBD商店买的，因为他们必须谈论当代问题，比如杂草在剧中半合法或什么的，以保持时效性。他们说，哦，好吧，你知道，大麻是一种毒品，即使它是合法的，女士，你也应该小心。你吃了多少？她说，哦，我吃了九个或十个。我只是，我笑得太多了。
Holy hell of a 75-year-old woman that had never tried marijuana eight nine weed cookies. Like, I don't... Anyway, yeah, so Matt Werner gets it right in the show Madman. And he says that they... I can never really figure out why they show this scene of this guy who has prodromal schizophrenia, who gets obsessed with the computer in the office and thinks it's surveilling him. And then he finally, you know, has a psychotic breakdown and it's really ugly. And it was like that...
一个从未尝试过大麻的75岁老太太吃了九个杂草饼干，天哪。像，我不……总之，是的，所以马特·韦纳在《广告狂人》中做对了。他说他们……我从来没弄明白为什么他们展示这个家伙的场景，他有前驱期精神分裂症，他沉迷于办公室里的计算机，认为它在监视他。然后他终于，你知道，精神崩溃了，这真的很丑陋。就像那样……
I like that character. I like that scene. I don't disagree with anything they did with it, but like, why is that there? Like, what's the theme that you're doing? And then after doing these series and like rewatching that show again, because this is one of my favorite shows, it was like, oh, like they're doing that because this is the time where psychosis started to change. And people were aware of like computers and data tracking and all of these things and that
我喜欢那个角色。我喜欢那个场景。我不同意他们用它做的任何事情，但像，为什么它在那里？像，你正在做的主题是什么？然后在做完这些系列并再次重看那部剧之后，因为这是我最喜欢的剧之一，就像，哦，他们这样做是因为这是精神病开始改变的时候。人们意识到像计算机、数据跟踪和所有这些事情，而这些
started to come out in psychotic episodes as they got increasingly paranoid. Psychosis, you know, the reports of psychosis that we have from the 40s and the 50s, there are a whole lot more about like people talking to ancestors being given help being told to you know cling to their faith being told to help other people i mean they're still distressing and they're still psychotic and they have the dysfunction that comes with something like schizophrenia that are you know not the auditory hallucination part but the psychosis the psychosis itself was not about competition and paranoia and it was not about the technology that psychotic episodes would start to take on it in the 75.
开始在精神病发作中显现出来，因为他们变得越来越偏执。精神病，你知道，我们从40年代和50年代得到的精神病报告，更多是关于人们与祖先交谈，被给予帮助，被告知要，你知道，坚持他们的信仰，被告知要帮助其他人，我的意思是，它们仍然令人痛苦，它们仍然是精神病的，它们有像精神分裂症那样带来的功能障碍，你知道，不是听觉幻觉部分，而是精神病本身，精神病本身不是关于竞争和偏执，它也不是关于精神病发作在75年开始采取的技术。
So it's like, I think that this stuff, 1990, 75 and onward, is where we really saw that expand. And then it hits like this huge zenith in the 90s. But I think that there is a relationship between the way that we are able to feel the culture that we're sort of aware of more than we're aware of. And these things do color how we think about ourselves. They do think about how we see the world. They color our religious and our psychotic experiences.
所以就像，我认为这些东西，1990年、75年及以后，是我们真正看到它扩展的地方。然后它在90年代达到了巨大的顶峰。但我认为，我们能够感受到的文化方式与我们意识到的东西之间存在一种关系，我们意识到的比我们意识到的要多。这些东西确实会影响我们对自己的看法。它们确实会影响我们看待世界的方式。它们影响我们的宗教和精神病体验。
I'm not saying religion and psychosis. I just mean that's kind of a transcendental, your ego is turned off thing. And there isn't a buffer that sorts all of this information. And so you can really see a lot of those unconscious assumptions when somebody is in a psychosis. And a lot of the things that come up with religion and psychedelics and trans states and people's personal spirituality also deal with those same places in the brain. And so it changes the way that they work. You know, religion changes when technology changes a lot of the time.
我并不是在说宗教和精神病。我只是指那是一种超验的、自我意识关闭的状态。大脑中没有一个缓冲区来整理所有这些信息。因此，当一个人处于精神病状态时，你确实可以看到许多潜意识的假设。而宗教、迷幻药、恍惚状态以及个人的灵性所涉及的许多事物，也都在处理大脑中相同的区域。所以这改变了它们运作的方式。你知道，宗教往往会随着技术的改变而改变。
And so all of this mistrust that the social worker is now your enemy, you know, the therapist is just trying to help you figure out how you play your games and how people play them against you so that you can play games better, which again, not indicting burn. I don't think that's this point. There's none of that in the book. It's how the culture takes it and runs with it because of the time that he writes it. And, you know, markets are automatically doing this. The butcher doesn't give you meat because he loves you. He gives you meat because he wants your money. And if you love the meat of the butcher down the street more,
因此，所有这些不信任感——认为社会工作者现在是你的敌人，你知道，治疗师只是试图帮你弄清楚你如何玩你的游戏，以及别人如何利用游戏来对付你，这样你就能玩得更好——这并不是在指责伯恩（Berne）。我不认为那是重点。书中没有这些内容。重点在于文化如何利用它并随之演变，因为他写作的那个时代背景。而且，你知道，市场会自动这样做。屠夫给你肉不是因为他爱你，他给你肉是因为他想要你的钱。如果你更喜欢街对面屠夫的肉，
you're going to pay that guy and not him. And so it's all self-interest, and it's channeled by competition, which under capitalism produces good outcomes as the economics at the time. So everything is subject to market forces. You privatize, you deregulate, you replace trust. with targets, you replace judgment with metrics, you replace relationships with transactions. And that's what this theory, public choice theory, is used by people like Margaret Thatcher and Ronald Reagan, is they can come in and say, the government's just this big fat thing that wants
你会付钱给那个人而不是他。所以这一切都是出于自身利益，并由竞争引导，在当时的经济学看来，这在资本主义下会产生良好的结果。因此，一切都受制于市场力量。你私有化，你放松管制，你用目标取代信任，用指标取代判断，用交易取代关系。这就是公共选择理论（Public Choice Theory），被玛格丽特·撒切尔和罗纳德·里根等人所利用，他们可以走进来并说，政府只是一个庞大而愚蠢的东西，它想要
you to have this lovey-dovey relationship with you where it takes care of you, but really it's big and dumb and it gets in the way. And what we need is accountability. If it's working, that's great. We're just going to make everybody spend all this time taking assessments and tests to really prove that the teacher isn't, you know, just drinking margaritas at work and the whatever, which, of course, these institutions had HR departments and accountability and all these things before, but politicians started to weaponize them in the 60s and the 70s and make them popular and act like this wasn't being done, which of course it was always being done. I mean, you couldn't be drunk on the job as a high school teacher in 1950. Like, you couldn't do it because there were
和你建立那种亲密无间的关系，照顾你，但实际上它又大又笨，只会碍手碍脚。我们需要的是问责制。如果它有效，那很好。我们只是要让每个人花所有时间进行评估和测试，以真正证明老师不是在工作中喝玛格丽特酒之类的，当然，这些机构在之前也有人力资源部门、问责制和所有这些东西，但政客们在60年代和70年代开始将它们武器化，使它们流行起来，并表现得好像以前没有这样做过，而事实上这一直都在做。我的意思是，1950年你不可能作为高中老师在工作中喝醉。就像，你做不到，因为有
accountability systems already built in. But the narrative becomes the government doesn't have any. of that. You have to ask for a job. Nobody, the government has to ask for a job, which I don't really understand the logic. I mean, you have to get elected or you have to get hired. If everybody could work for the government, I guess they all would. But, you know, I've talked about Theodore Porter before. I really like Theodore Porter's book, Trust in Numbers. We talked about that a lot through the DSM series. But in trust in numbers, Porter argues that there's something counterintuitive. That like quantitative rigor is not primarily about truth. It's about distrust. And you're seeing an example of this here because they start to tell everybody,
已经建立好的问责系统。但叙事变成了政府没有任何问责。你必须申请工作。没人，政府必须申请工作，我不明白这个逻辑。我的意思是，你必须当选或者被雇佣。如果每个人都能为政府工作，我想他们都会去。但是，你知道，我之前谈到过西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）。我真的很喜欢西奥多·波特的书《信任数字》（Trust in Numbers）。我们在DSM系列中经常讨论这个问题。但在《信任数字》中，波特认为有一些反直觉的东西。就像量化严谨性主要不是关于真理，而是关于不信任。你在这里看到了一个例子，因为他们开始告诉每个人，
you, we can't take your word for it. We can't trust you. You have to be on guard all the time, proving that you're doing a good job because we're going through your numbers. Do your patients die more often than other patients? Do your patients get better, better than other patients? We can't trust the patient to, you know, assess you. We have to have these objective, just say what they're experience, was it good or bad and complain if they have a bad experience, we have to have these hard numbers that govern everything. And so a lot of, you know, what I'm critiquing here are some of the inevitabilities of bureaucracy, but we should still be aware of them because we can mitigate them. And if we don't, if we're not aware of them, and we don't mitigate them, they're going to be used
你，我们不能听信你的一面之词。我们不能信任你。你必须时刻保持警惕，证明你做得很好，因为我们要检查你的数据。你的病人死亡率是否比其他病人高？你的病人是否比其他病人恢复得更好？我们不能信任病人来评估你。我们必须有这些客观的——只是说出他们的体验是好是坏，如果体验不好就投诉——我们必须有这些硬性指标来管理一切。所以，你知道，我在这里批评的很多是官僚主义的一些必然性，但我们仍然应该意识到它们，因为我们可以减轻它们。如果我们不这样做，如果我们没有意识到它们，并且不减轻它们，它们就会被用来
to exploit you. So, you know, thinking about, you know, if you trust your doctor, you accept their judgment, take this medication. Okay, doctor, I'll take the medication. If you don't trust them, then you demand metrics. Show me studies. What are the outcomes? what is the evidence basis for the medication, which in many cases you probably should be able to do. The accountability should be there, but the accountability should be a part of every system. But when you make it the point of the system, then you lose the real point. And so Porter's thesis is when society stops trusting experts, it replaces them with audits. You know, you pivot to numbers at times of insecurity.
剥削你。所以，你知道，想想看，如果你信任你的医生，你接受他们的判断，服用这种药物。好的，医生，我会服药。如果你不信任他们，那么你就会要求指标。给我看研究。结果是什么？药物的证据基础是什么？在许多情况下，你可能应该能够这样做。问责制应该存在，但问责制应该是每个系统的一部分。但当你把它变成系统的核心目的时，你就失去了真正的意义。所以波特的论点是，当社会停止信任专家时，它就用审计来取代他们。你知道，在不安全的时候，你会转向数字。
And I think coming out of the oil embargo and Reagan wanting to be this big bravado cowboy boy who was going to be tough and get America back working by being, you know, tough or something. He definitely was acting from this place of insecurity. He's not Carter, you know, the crisis of confidence speech where Carter says, can we have like one point to America that isn't just like getting more stuff than someone else? Could we re-envision the myth and maybe make it about something other than just getting more stuff? And then people say, no, we want more stuff. That's the worst thing you can ever do to America, has asked them to have a different myth than the one we're on already. And the crisis of confidence bombs. Carter leaves. Reagan comes in and pivots to objectivity.
我认为，在石油禁运之后，里根想要成为那种虚张声势的牛仔，他要表现得强硬，通过表现得强硬或类似的东西让美国重新运转起来。他绝对是出于这种不安全感。他不是卡特，你知道，在那个“信心危机”演讲中，卡特说，我们能不能在美国找到一点，不仅仅是比别人得到更多东西？我们能不能重新构想这个神话，也许让它不仅仅是关于得到更多东西？然后人们说，不，我们想要更多东西。这是你能对美国做的最糟糕的事情，就是要求他们拥有一个与我们现有的不同的神话。于是信心危机失败了。卡特离开了。里根上台，转向客观性。
And, you know, the new world runs on this mechanical objectivity. You don't trust anyone. You can't. Everyone's a game player, remember. So you need rules. You need forms. You need metrics. You need targets. The idea of gaming the system, that there was some way, if you just filled out enough forms, the government would pay you money for the rest of your life. And the idea that you needed to means test everything, that there couldn't do. be a universal system again. You know, Medicaid, Medicaid is probably one of the last universal systems that we'll ever have. Everything else is like, well, you can have it like if you're a single mom that also recovered from drugs, and then you have more than three kids, and you live in the SIP code.
而且，你知道，新世界运行在这种机械的客观性上。你不信任任何人。你不能。每个人都是游戏玩家，记住。所以你需要规则。你需要表格。你需要指标。你需要目标。关于操纵系统的想法，即如果只要你填写的表格足够多，政府就会付钱给你直到你余生结束。以及你需要对一切进行经济状况调查（means test）的想法，即不可能再有一个普遍的系统。你知道，医疗补助（Medicaid）可能是我们永远拥有的最后一个普遍系统之一。其他一切都是，嗯，如果你是一个单身母亲，也从毒瘾中恢复过来，然后你有三个以上的孩子，并且你住在这个邮政编码区，你就可以拥有它。
And means testing is, you know, the way that we do legislation now. It's about distrust, making sure that the wrong person doesn't get this government benefit. And so this is this bridge between John Nash's paranoid math, and that Reagan and Thatcher, revolution. If you believe in that Nash worldview that everyone is just playing games for selfish advantage, then you can't allow experts to use their judgment. You can't trust them. You have to strip the expert of power and you replace it with a manual.
而经济状况调查，你知道，是我们现在进行立法的方式。它是关于不信任，确保错误的人不会得到这种政府福利。所以这就是约翰·纳什（John Nash）的偏执数学与里根和撒切尔革命之间的桥梁。如果你相信纳什那种每个人都只是为了自私利益而玩游戏的世界观，那么你就不能允许专家使用他们的判断。你不能信任他们。你必须剥夺专家的权力，并用手册取而代之。
And the manual is really the expert because it knows the code to the machine, which is one of the reasons why when I'm saying, yes, there's huge problems with the DSM 1 and 2 in the first part of this kind of mini season that we're doing, I don't love the checklist of the three because I don't, that they just hide the subjective bias from the practitioner, not make the subjective bias go away. In a soft science, I think the subjectivity is inevitable. And so Ronald Reagan and Margaret Thatcher come to power on this philosophy. They didn't trust public servants. They didn't trust institutions.
而手册实际上就是专家，因为它知道机器的代码，这就是为什么我说，是的，在我们正在做的这个迷你季的第一部分中，DSM 1和2存在巨大的问题，我不喜欢DSM 3的检查表，因为我不喜欢它们只是向从业者隐藏了主观偏见，而不是让主观偏见消失。在软科学中，我认为主观性是不可避免的。所以罗纳德·里根和玛格丽特·撒切尔凭借这种哲学上台。他们不信任公务员。他们不信任机构。
They assumed everyone was this Nashian agent playing games for personal advantage. And it works because people's blood pressure gets up. And they want to, you know, it gets up, sorry. And they they want to hear more about this thing. And they start treating politics as the this extension of themselves, like football. Politics was kind of boring before. You know, people viewed it as the civic obligation, not this thing that they were obsessed with doing. And so only individuals exist.
他们假设每个人都是这种纳什式的代理人，为了个人利益而玩游戏。这很有效，因为人们的血压升高了。他们想要，你知道，它升高了，抱歉。他们想要听到更多关于这件事的信息。他们开始把政治视为他们自己的延伸，就像足球一样。政治在以前是有点无聊的。你知道，人们把它视为公民义务，而不是他们痴迷于做的事情。所以只有个人存在。
And individuals are self-interested calculators, like in that system. And this is the beginning of that happening. So Thatcher introduced targets and performance metrics throughout the British public sector. You can't trust a doctor to do their job out of duty, so you have to measure their outputs and punish them if they fall short. You can't trust a teacher to educate, you know, just out of the, you know, just out of vocation or calling. They're really trying to scam somebody. So you must test the students and then rank the schools and the test captures how good of a job the teacher did. It's all able to be
而个人是自私的计算者，就像在那个系统中一样。这就是这一切开始的开端。所以撒切尔在整个英国公共部门引入了目标和绩效指标。你不能信任医生出于责任感去做好他们的工作，所以你必须衡量他们的产出，如果他们达不到要求就惩罚他们。你不能信任老师出于职业或使命感去教育。他们真的在试图欺骗某人。所以你必须测试学生，然后对学校进行排名，测试结果捕捉到了老师做得有多好。这一切都可以
turned into a number. And Reagan did a similar thing in America. You know, deregulation, privatization. The assumption that the government is this problem because the government is run by self-interested game players who can't be trusted. And so the welfare state was dismantled, not because it was too expensive because it was based on this false premise. It assumed public service wanted to help people. Game theory says that's naive. They don't. And it was just targets and metrics. And in America, we weaponize the law itself to enforce this isolation. So you know why therapists can't unionize like I talked about in the last episode. But let me connect this to that philosophical argument, that Sherman Antitrust Act, written in 1890 to break up standard oil. It prohibits every contract, combination, or conspiracy and restraint of trade. Trade is the highest goal of the country. And it was designed to prevent massive corporations from colluding to fix prices and destroy competition. But in the eyes of the federal government, a private practice therapist is not a worker. You're a business entity.
变成一个数字。里根在美国也做了类似的事情。你知道，放松管制，私有化。假设政府是一个问题，因为政府是由不能被信任的自私游戏玩家经营的。所以福利国家被拆除了，不是因为它太贵，而是因为它基于这个错误的假设。它假设公共服务人员想要帮助人们。博弈论说那是天真的。他们不想。这只是目标和指标。在美国，我们利用法律本身来强制这种孤立。所以你知道为什么治疗师不能像我在上一集谈到的那样组建工会。但让我把它与那个哲学论点联系起来，那个1890年为了拆分标准石油公司而写的《谢尔曼反托拉斯法》（Sherman Antitrust Act）。它禁止任何限制贸易的合同、组合或共谋。贸易是国家的最高目标。它的设计初衷是防止大型企业串通定价和破坏竞争。但在联邦政府眼中，私人执业治疗师不是工人。你是一个商业实体。
So even if you're a solo practitioner struggling to pay rent in a sub-leased office, the law views you as a CEO of a micro corporation. So if two workers at Starbucks talk about their wages and they agree to ask for a raise, that's collective bargaining. But if two private practice therapists talk about their reimbursement rates and agree to Blue Cross, for a race, that's price fixing. It's illegal. It's indistinguishable in the eyes of the law, but the law defines you as this standard oil tycoon because you have a company that is just you doing therapy. It requires you to view all of your colleagues as a competitor, and if you try to practice solidarity, you go to jail. So the law forces you to be isolated, suspicious, you know, agent in competition with other things. You can't collude. And it's not just a vibe. Like that's
所以即使你是一个在转租办公室里努力支付租金的个体执业者，法律也将你视为微型公司的首席执行官。所以如果星巴克的两名员工谈论他们的工资并同意要求加薪，那是集体谈判。但如果两名私人执业治疗师谈论他们的报销率并同意向蓝十字保险公司要求加薪，那是价格操纵。这是非法的。在法律眼中它们是无法区分的，但法律将你定义为这个标准石油大亨，因为你有一个公司，而这个公司只是你自己做治疗。它要求你将所有同事视为竞争对手，如果你试图实践团结，你就会坐牢。所以法律迫使你成为一个孤立的、多疑的、与其他事物竞争的代理人。你不能串通。而且这不仅仅是一种氛围。就像那是
federal statute. And it's when they enforce. And so meanwhile, if you have a market cap under $4 billion, there's a secret committee called the RUC, we talked about before, you know, that relative value scale update committee, where surgical specialists have to meet behind closed doors to set prices for the entire healthcare industry. But they're legally protected because they're technically advising the government. The same action that would be a federal crime for a therapist is protected actively for surgeons. And the system doesn't just assume that we're selfish game. players. It legally requires us to be selfish game players. Solidarity is criminalized and competition is mandated. But remember what's leaked out of the RUC that we talked about last time, the log rolling.
联邦法规。而且这是他们执行的。所以与此同时，如果你的市值低于40亿美元，有一个秘密委员会叫RUC，我们之前谈到过，你知道，那个相对价值量表更新委员会，外科专家必须在闭门会议中为整个医疗行业定价。但他们受到法律保护，因为他们从技术上讲是在为政府提供建议。同样的行动，如果治疗师做就是联邦犯罪，但对外科医生来说却是被积极保护的。这个系统不仅假设我们是自私的游戏玩家。它在法律上要求我们成为自私的游戏玩家。团结被定为犯罪，竞争被强制执行。但记住我们上次谈到的从RUC泄露出来的东西，那种利益交换（log rolling）。
They're already playing games within that RUC system where they're saying, hey, we want to ice psychiatry out and only has one vote. I'm a foot doctor. You're a heart doctor. But I'll agree to make my specialty worth more. I'll make your special. worth more if you make mine worth more because we're both highly technocratic people that have to have all this technology to do a very specific skill which is probably not a very high and counterpoint for most of the American public like most of the American public would probably not benefit from these teeny tiny specialties that are needed and should exist sucking up all of those billions of dollars they probably would like their primary care doctor to be have a little bit more time and
他们已经在那个RUC系统中玩游戏了，他们说，嘿，我们想把精神病学排除在外，它只有一个投票权。我是足科医生。你是心脏科医生。但我会同意让我的专业价值更高。如果你让我的专业价值更高，我也会让你的专业价值更高，因为我们都是高度技术官僚的人，必须拥有所有这些技术来完成一项非常具体的技能，这对大多数美国公众来说可能不是一个很高的反论点，就像大多数美国公众可能不会从这些需要存在且应该存在的微小专业中受益，它们吸走了所有这些数十亿美元，他们可能希望他们的初级保健医生有更多一点时间，
be easier to see or a psychiatrist or a therapist but the money doesn't go that way and so So the whole idea of competition, that thing that we talked about in the Ken Therapist Start a Union episode, the RUC was designed to get rid of, collusion. You just moved that to a committee of 29 people doing it instead of getting rid of it. You just made it simpler. And so that is where the Adam Curtis argument gets really dark, right? By the way, like the argument there, what I'm saying, again, is here's another example. of you saying that you're going to take subjectivity out of a system, make it totally objective. But what you did is just hide the subjectivity for yourself.
更容易见到，或者精神科医生或治疗师，但钱并没有流向那边。所以整个竞争的概念，我们在《治疗师能组建工会吗》那一集中谈到的东西，RUC的设计初衷就是为了摆脱串通。你只是把它转移到了一个由29个人组成的委员会中，而不是摆脱它。你只是让它变得更简单了。所以这就是亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis）的论点变得非常黑暗的地方，对吧？顺便说一句，就像那里的论点，我所说的是，这又是另一个例子，你声称要从系统中剔除主观性，使其完全客观。但你所做的只是为你自己隐藏了主观性。
Nobody knows why psych got disfunded. Nobody knows why psychiatry is undervalued and then the market forces people to go out of it. But it was because we said, hey, here's the RUC, here's this totally objective group of experts that's going to get it done so that doctors can't just kind of fight about it in private practice. And what did you do? You just moved a rule of 29 people playing the same game. and it probably ended worse. So we created this system based on assumptions that humans are selfish, isolated game players,
没人知道为什么精神病学被削减了资金。没人知道为什么精神病学被低估，然后市场力量迫使人们离开它。但这是因为我们说，嘿，这是RUC，这是这个完全客观的专家组，它会搞定这件事，这样医生们就不能在私人执业中为了这件事而争吵。你做了什么？你只是转移了一个由29个人玩同样游戏的规则。而且结果可能更糟。所以我们创建了这个系统，基于人类是自私的、孤立的游戏玩家的假设，
and then we told everybody, this book, The Games People Play, and a thousand similar cultural products, you know, that are like that. Their relationships were just strategic transactions. We built a political and economic system that rewards selfish behaviors and punishes altruism. And if you try and act out of duty or compassion,
然后我们告诉每个人，这本书《人们玩的游戏》（The Games People Play），以及一千个类似的文化产品，你知道，都是那样的。他们的关系只是战略交易。我们建立了一个奖励自私行为、惩罚利他主义的政治和经济系统。如果你试图出于责任或同情心行事，
then you're just a sucker who's playing a game. You're playing the victim. And the system isn't designed for that. The system is designed for rational self-interest. And we made it illegal to organize against the system. You know, the Sherman Act doesn't let us do that. We have to view ourselves this way. We can't work together, which again, the Sherman Act has passed for good reason, standard oil, selling oil, you know, below the cost of oil to put competitors out of business so they can charge everyone more.
那么你只是一个玩游戏的傻瓜。你在扮演受害者。而这个系统不是为那个设计的。这个系统是为理性的自身利益设计的。而且我们使反对这个系统变得非法。你知道，谢尔曼法案不允许我们这样做。我们必须这样看待自己。我们不能一起工作，这再次说明，谢尔曼法案通过是有充分理由的，标准石油，以低于石油成本的价格销售石油，以将竞争对手挤出市场，这样他们就可以向每个人收取更多费用。
You know, we don't want to be corporate slaves, so we got to regulate these things. I think the Sherman Act's fine. Let's look how it's being applied now, though. This is the trap. You know, we eventually become the creatures the model describes, even if we weren't when we started the model. We started behaving like isolated, suspicious, calculating individuals because the system left us no other choice. And if everyone around you is playing games, you have to play games too to survive. If the institutions assume that you're selfish, you might as well be selfish.
你知道，我们不想成为企业奴隶，所以我们必须监管这些事情。我认为谢尔曼法案很好。但让我们看看它现在是如何被应用的。这就是陷阱。你知道，我们最终变成了模型所描述的生物，即使我们在开始模型时不是这样。我们开始表现得像孤立的、多疑的、精于计算的个人，因为系统没有给我们其他选择。如果周围的每个人都在玩游戏，为了生存，你也必须玩游戏。如果机构假设你是自私的，你最好还是自私点。
If trust is for suckers, only a sucker would trust. And if solidarity is illegal, then you can only look out for yourself. So the paranoid vision became this self-fulfilling prophet. And Nash's schizophrenic worldview, paranoid schizophrenic worldview, that of a man who saw conspiracies and betrayals everywhere becomes this operating system of Western Empire. And I want to tell you about one more person because the story is interesting. George Price, who Curtis also mentions, he's a scientist who in the 1960s developed something called the Price equation. And it's this mathematical formula that explains how altruism works in nature. And so the formula proved something devastating.
如果信任是给傻瓜的，只有傻瓜才会信任。如果团结是非法的，那么你只能顾及自己。所以这种偏执的愿景变成了自我实现的预言。纳什的精神分裂世界观，偏执型精神分裂世界观，一个到处看到阴谋和背叛的人的世界观，变成了西方帝国的操作系统。我想再告诉你一个人，因为这个故事很有趣。乔治·普莱斯（George Price），柯蒂斯也提到了他，他是一位科学家，在20世纪60年代开发了一种叫做“普莱斯方程”（Price equation）的东西。这是一个解释利他主义在自然界中如何运作的数学公式。所以这个公式证明了一些毁灭性的东西。
When an animal helps another animal, it isn't doing it out of kindness. It's just doing it because other animals share its genes. So altruism is just a strategy. It's just a game for getting your own genes onto the next generation. And mathematically, altruism is impossible. Every act of love and sacrifice and every moment of compassion, it's all just selfish gene to play a game. And this is Nash's paranoid vision, you know, applied to biolns.
当一种动物帮助另一种动物时，它不是出于善良。它只是因为其他动物分享它的基因。所以利他主义只是一种策略。这只是为了让自己的基因进入下一代的游戏。从数学上讲，利他主义是不可能的。每一个爱和牺牲的行为，每一个同情的时刻，都只是自私基因在玩游戏。这就是纳什的偏执愿景，你知道，应用于生物学。
and the math checks out. But here's the difference between Price and the economists who celebrate this worldview. Price is horrified. Like he went out to study altruism because he was an altruist and he wanted to kind of find the human in the math and he found something in the math that made the human not human. It just made it a game or a math problem that was trying to self-replicate its code on the biggest and biggest scale. And when Price sees that his math is telling him, which I don't think it is, but what he thought was the math is telling me that I'm just a self-interested creature that can't do anything nice. Even if I try, I can't stop playing a game.
而且数学上是成立的。但这就是普莱斯与那些赞美这种世界观的经济学家之间的区别。普莱斯感到恐惧。他去研究利他主义是因为他是一个利他主义者，他想在数学中找到人性，但他发现数学中的某些东西让人不再是人。它只是让它变成了一个游戏或一个数学问题，试图在最大规模上自我复制它的代码。当普莱斯看到他的数学告诉他——我不认为它是这样，但他认为数学告诉他——我只是一个自私的生物，什么好事都做不了。即使我尝试，我也无法停止玩游戏。
And it kind of drives him mad. He didn't want to be a machine. He didn't want to be a calculation. He wanted there to be altruism, and he didn't want his own discovery to be true. And so there's some, so he tried to just prove it. He decided to perform an act of pure, uncalculated altruism, an act that gave him. an act that gave no genetic or social advantage. And he starts giving away all of his stuff.
这让他有点发疯。他不想成为一台机器。他不想成为一个计算结果。他希望利他主义存在，他不希望自己的发现是真的。所以有一些，所以他试图证明它。他决定进行一次纯粹的、未经计算的利他主义行为，一种没有给予他任何基因或社会优势的行为。他开始分发他所有的东西。
He invited homeless people to live in his apartment. And he gave away all of his money. And he impoverished himself trying to be genuinely good. And it didn't work. He realized that he was still getting something out of it. It was there is a psychological payoff that the feeling of being righteous, the satisfaction of sacrifice was maybe just this reward that the code was giving him. And even in his extreme altruism, he saw this game and he was still trading, still calculating, and he was still trapped.
他邀请无家可归的人住进他的公寓。他分发了他所有的钱。他让自己变得贫穷，试图变得真正善良。但这没用。他意识到他仍然从中得到了什么。有一种心理回报，那种正义感，牺牲的满足感，也许只是代码给他的奖励。即使在他极端的利他主义中，他也看到了这个游戏，他仍然在交易，仍然在计算，他仍然被困住了。
And so in 75, George Price commits suicide after going down this rabbit hole of grieving like something that he sees as a true discovery. And he does it because he can't escape this logic. He can't live in a world where love is just an equation, where kindness is just a strategy, where everything is a game. and Curtis uses this image to show in Adam Curtis's movie, which is called All Watched Over by Machines of Loving Grace, he uses that image to show this ultimate cost of the worldview that we've built. Price bleeds out because the trap has no exit. And if neoliberalism is true, you know,
所以在75年，乔治·普莱斯在陷入这种悲伤的兔子洞后自杀了，因为他认为这是一个真实的发现。他这样做是因为他无法逃避这种逻辑。他无法生活在一个爱只是一个等式、善良只是一个策略、一切都是游戏的世界里。柯蒂斯在亚当·柯蒂斯的电影中使用了这个形象，电影名为《机器守护着爱的恩典》（All Watched Over by Machines of Loving Grace），他用那个形象展示了我们建立的世界观的最终代价。普莱斯流血而死，因为这个陷阱没有出口。如果新自由主义是真的，你知道，
if that neoliberal market based on that competition and paranoia is true, then we're really just selfish machines calculating payoffs and life is not worth living. But I would argue that none of us could live in the world, that Price thought that we were inhabiting. There's not anything that is fulfilling about looking at the world in the way that his discovery forced him to look at it. And that that is sort of becoming this unconscious assumption baked into our systems that is making, breaking therapy and making life very hard to live for a lot of the reasons
如果那个基于竞争和偏执的新自由主义市场是真的，那么我们真的只是计算回报的自私机器，生活不值得过。但我会争辩说，我们中没有人能生活在普莱斯认为我们所居住的世界里。以他发现迫使他看待世界的方式来看待世界，没有任何令人满足的地方。而且这正在成为我们系统中根深蒂固的潜意识假设，它正在破坏治疗，并使生活变得非常难以过下去，原因有很多
that people bring into therapy. And I'm hoping that if some of those unconscious assumptions can be things that we can observe, then we can feel separate and free from them, even if practically we're still dependent on them. You know, Byrne is not a villain. He wasn't trying to create this nightmare. He genuinely wanted to help people, and he thought that by exposing the games we play unconsciously, he could free us from them. I think of his book was applied in the way it was written. It probably would. I mean, I use it. It's good at doing that. But he believed in something that he called game-free intimacy, the possibility of authentic connection between people who aren't manipulating each other.
人们带入治疗中。我希望如果其中一些潜意识假设可以成为我们可以观察到的东西，那么我们就可以感到与它们分离并从中解脱，即使在实践中我们仍然依赖它们。你知道，伯恩不是恶棍。他并没有试图制造这个噩梦。他真心想帮助人们，他认为通过揭露我们潜意识中玩的游戏，他可以让我们从中解脱。我认为如果他的书按照它写的方式被应用。它可能会。我的意思是，我使用它。它很擅长做那个。但他相信他称之为“无游戏亲密关系”（game-free intimacy）的东西，即在不操纵彼此的人之间进行真实连接的可能性。
And that was the goal. I think that John Nash, reason that people point to it and say, yes, you know, we do need to live in this paranoid, neoliberal, hyper-capitalist, hyper-competitive world, because look at all of the things that happened when people were trusting. I would say, yes, correct. I know that those exist. I also try and avoid those things, but have we forgotten that those interactions happen when people are deeply sick? And the point of life is to find the people who aren't and make the people who are sick better so that we can have this authenticity. And I think that psychology itself, through the things that we talked about in the last four
这就是目标。我认为约翰·纳什，人们指出它并说，是的，你知道，我们确实需要生活在这个偏执的、新自由主义的、超资本主义的、超竞争的世界里，因为看看当人们信任时发生的所有事情。我会说，是的，正确。我知道那些存在。我也尽量避免那些事情，但我们是否忘记了那些互动发生在人们病得很重的时候？而生活的意义在于找到那些没有病的人，并让那些生病的人好起来，这样我们才能拥有这种真实性。我认为心理学本身，通过我们在过去四集中谈到的事情，
episodes, you know, the clinical application of it is forgetting that. It is fallen prey to these same forces. You know, those games were obstacles to be overcome. They were not the human, you know, the truth of human nature. And when Price started to see himself as a game, it drives him into madness. It drives him into a paranoid schizophrenia where even his altruistic interactions with people, he can't feel joy or beauty in them, which is so sad. And what the culture received at this time were we are game players, our relationships or
你知道，它的临床应用正在忘记这一点。它已经沦为这些相同力量的牺牲品。你知道，那些游戏是需要克服的障碍。它们不是人类，你知道，人性的真理。当普莱斯开始把自己视为一个游戏时，这让他陷入了疯狂。这让他陷入了偏执型精神分裂症，即使是他与人的利他互动，他也无法从中感受到快乐或美，这太悲伤了。而当时文化所接收到的是，我们是游戏玩家，我们的关系是
transactions, authenticity is naive, everyone has an angle. And Byrne gave the public a vocabulary for the Nash worldview. He made it accessible. He made it common sense. He made it not a household name, but a household assumption. And it once was, you know, common sense the political implementation would follow. Reagan and Thatcher, you know, didn't have to convince anyone that humans are selfish calculators. Everyone already knew that.
交易，真实性是天真的，每个人都有自己的意图。伯恩为公众提供了一种纳什世界观的词汇。他使它变得易于理解。他使它成为常识。他使它不是一个家喻户晓的名字，而是一个家喻户晓的假设。一旦它成为，你知道，常识，政治实施就会随之而来。里根和撒切尔，你知道，不需要说服任何人人类是自私的计算者。每个人都已经知道了。
And they'd read about it in this best-selling pop psychology book and from a million other places that are latching on to this idea that becomes this kind of new liberalism. The freedom of the market above all else means that you have less freedom if you hinder the market. And so Nash provides this mathematical model that humans are selfish agents. And Byrne provides the cultural language that life is a game, social norms or manipulation. And Porter explains the mechanism. When trust dies, numbers rule. And numbers are a low trust environment. There is no trust in numbers.
他们已经在这一本畅销的流行心理学书中读到过，并从其他一百万个地方了解到这个想法，这个想法变成了这种新自由主义。市场高于一切的自由意味着如果你阻碍市场，你的自由就更少。所以纳什提供了人类是自私代理人的数学模型。伯恩提供了生活是一场游戏、社会规范是操纵的文化语言。而波特解释了机制。当信任死亡时，数字统治一切。而数字是一个低信任环境。数字中没有信任。
And so when neoliberalism provided the political implementation, we dismantle the institutions built on trust. And we unleash the market to manage these selfish agents. And so, you know, now think about what happens to therapy specifically, because that's where Nash's paranoid math arrives, you know, in the consulting room. You know, Aaron Beck is watching the chaos of 1970s psychotherapy, where people are going into psychosis and they're like New Age Faith healer licensed therapist is telling them it's a genuine spiritual awakening. I mean, transactional analysis died, by the way, around this time
所以当新自由主义提供政治实施时，我们拆除了建立在信任基础上的机构。我们释放市场来管理这些自私的代理人。所以，你知道，现在想想治疗具体发生了什么，因为那是纳什的偏执数学到达的地方，你知道，在咨询室里。你知道，亚伦·贝克（Aaron Beck）正在观察1970年代心理治疗的混乱，人们陷入精神病状态，他们就像新时代的信仰治疗师，持证治疗师告诉他们这是一种真正的精神觉醒。我的意思是，交易分析（Transactional Analysis）在那个时候死掉了，顺便说一句，
because one lady who took this book about analyzing games that is pretty good, Reddit and then said this applies to attachment theory because the baby's playing a game or something. And if you have bad attachment with your mom because she was like bad to you, you shouldn't like work on that through relational counseling. What you should do is resimulate birth through rebirthing with an adult person in front of their mother. So you like wrap them up in towels like they're being born and like get them really tight so they can't breathe and then pull them out and they rego through the trauma.
因为一位女士读了这本关于分析游戏的书，觉得它相当不错，然后说这适用于依恋理论，因为婴儿在玩游戏或类似的东西。如果你和妈妈有糟糕的依恋，因为她对你不好，你不应该通过关系咨询来解决这个问题。你应该做的是通过在母亲面前与成年人进行重生（rebirthing）来重新模拟出生。所以你把他们用毛巾裹起来，就像他们正在出生一样，把他们裹得很紧，让他们无法呼吸，然后把他们拉出来，他们重新经历创伤。
None of this is. I'm making the point that this is. crazy because it is. And then when the towel weight comes off of them, then they feel like they were born and they see their mom and they have reattachment, you don't have to do like therapy at any point. You just strangle people with a towel. So not only did this not work, it killed one, maybe two people that like choked on the towel. So like this is psychotherapy in the 1970s. The CIA is paying like, you know, to have like dolphins be taught English by given LSD. And, you know, that's what the military.
这些都不是。我指出这一点是因为这很疯狂，因为事实确实如此。然后当毛巾重量从他们身上拿开时，他们感觉就像他们出生了一样，他们看到了他们的妈妈，他们有了重新依恋，你根本不需要做治疗。你只是用毛巾勒死人。所以这不仅没有奏效，它还杀了一个，也许两个在毛巾上窒息的人。所以这就是1970年代的心理治疗。中央情报局正在付钱，你知道，让海豚通过服用LSD来学习英语。而且，你知道，这就是军队
Terry's doing is trying to see if identical twins can like see through each other's minds. If you have one look in a rose in any other room and then maybe we'll be able to defeat the Soviets with this. So like what do you think therapists are doing when that's what the four stars are doing? Like this was a wild time. What do you think the therapists that are like taking the LSD and smoking the marijuana in California were doing? I'm not defending therapy at this point.
正在做的事情，试图看看同卵双胞胎是否能像看穿彼此的思想一样。如果你让一个人在另一个房间看一朵玫瑰，也许我们就能用这个打败苏联。所以，你知道，当四星上将都在做这些事情时，你认为治疗师在做什么？就像这是一个疯狂的时代。你认为那些在加州服用LSD和吸食大麻的治疗师在做什么？我此时并不在为治疗辩护。
You know, people have emailed me and said like Wilhelm Reich was bad. I saw somebody who was disciple that was an abusive whatever. if you can't just recognize Reich as a historical guy who came up with somatic psychotherapy and wrote a sort of good book on fascism who also was crazy, like if you can't see him, if you're continuing to try and do anything like that run, you know, from that person,
你知道，人们给我发邮件说威廉·赖希（Wilhelm Reich）很糟糕。我看到有人是他的门徒，是一个虐待狂什么的。如果你不能仅仅承认赖希是一个提出了躯体心理治疗并写了一本关于法西斯主义的好书的历史人物，他同时也是个疯子，就像如果你不能看清他，如果你继续试图做任何类似的事情，跑，你知道，离开那个人，
there are so many incompetent therapists at this point. There's so much wildness of the 70s and psychonautica. And there's bad therapists now. Like, I'm not defending any of these people because I recognize their place. in history. I have different thoughts about all of them, but they are important, you know. So Beck is watching this when he watches 900 people drink Kool-Aid and die in
此时有太多的无能治疗师。70年代和精神探索（psychonautica）有太多的狂野。现在也有糟糕的治疗师。就像，我并不为这些人中的任何一个辩护，因为我承认他们在历史中的位置。我对他们每个人都有不同的想法，但他们很重要，你知道。所以贝克在观察这一切，当他看到900人喝下毒药并在
Jonestown. And he's seen boundaries dissolve between therapists and client. You know, he's seen encounter groups become trauma reenactment and, you know, weird like celebration of how you have like a right because when you contact the trauma, it makes you want to do this to like abuse other people, all kinds of crazy stuff. stuff and he'd seen people with legitimate, you know, mental health issues be failed by the system. And so, and again, I don't blame Beck, even though I don't love CVT, because I think he's an inevitability. You know, Beck had a different idea.
琼斯镇（Jonestown）死去。他看到了治疗师和客户之间的界限消失。你知道，他看到了遭遇小组（encounter groups）变成了创伤重演，你知道，奇怪的庆祝你如何拥有权利，因为当你接触到创伤时，它让你想这样做来虐待其他人，各种各样的疯狂事情。而且他看到有合法心理健康问题的人被系统辜负了。所以，而且再次，我不怪贝克，尽管我不喜欢CBT，因为我认为他是必然的。你知道，贝克有一个不同的想法。
He wanted to throw all that out, Reich's body, Jung, soul, Perlzes, experiments, Freud's unconscious, get rid of all that stuff. And then you can measure all of these things with numbers, and you can hold people accountable. And unlike Reagan and Thatcher, I think that Beck wasn't just trying to use numbers to get what he wanted anyway. He wasn't using them to manufacture a solution. I think he really believed it. And so cognitive behavioral therapy is born and it fits perfectly into this Nash Porter framework. You can't trust a therapist to use their judgment. So you manualize the treatment. We've already manualized the manual at the DSM3. So let's go ahead and turn therapy into a manualized treatment too. You can't trust subjective reports of improvement. You can't come up with your own hunches.
他想把所有那些东西都扔掉，赖希的身体，荣格的灵魂，珀尔斯的实验，弗洛伊德的潜意识，摆脱所有那些东西。然后你可以用数字衡量所有这些事情，你可以让人们负责。而且与里根和撒切尔不同，我认为贝克不仅仅是试图用数字来得到他想要的。他不是用它们来制造解决方案。我认为他真的相信它。所以认知行为疗法（CBT）诞生了，它完美地契合了这个纳什-波特框架。你不能信任治疗师使用他们的判断。所以你把治疗手册化。我们已经在DSM3中把手册手册化了。所以让我们继续把治疗也变成一种手册化的治疗。你不能信任主观的改善报告。你不能提出你自己的预感。
You can't say, hey, I've noticed that most of my ASD people do this. So I'm just going to act on that assumption even though I haven't read anything about that yet because nothing's been researched on it yet. You know, you can't trust the therapeutic relationship. So you just minimize it and you focus on technique. And so CBT is quantifiable. You fill out a pHQ 9 before and then after it was 80% sad. Now I'm 40% sad. You've proved improvement. My argument here is when you spend all of your time trying to prove something's happening, you don't spend all of your time making it happen. And that's what happens, you know, when this stuff. enters the health care market. We found now, you know, going back through it, health care outcomes
你不能说，嘿，我注意到我的ASD（自闭症谱系障碍）患者大多这样做。所以我只是要根据那个假设行事，尽管我还没有读过任何关于那个的东西，因为还没有任何关于它的研究。你知道，你不能信任治疗关系。所以你只是最小化它，你专注于技术。所以CBT是可量化的。你在之前填写一份PHQ-9，然后在之后，它是80%悲伤。现在我是40%悲伤。你证明了改善。我在这里的论点是，当你花所有时间试图证明某事正在发生时，你并没有花所有时间让它发生。这就是当这些东西进入医疗市场时发生的事情。我们现在发现，你知道，回顾过去，医疗结果
got way worse when we started doing the kind of Reagan-Datcher accountability revolutions in Britain and in America. It's just that we changed the goalpost so that the numbers looked like we were better so that we didn't lose our funding, you know, the hospital did. So, and that happens in both countries because people start spending all of their time trying to prove that they're doing their job instead of actually doing their job. And while you're, you're doing that, you know, HR department of a lifestyle, you also lose people who actually felt called to go do the thing because they're not doing it anymore. So you have teachers who are going to settle for $30,000 a year and nurses and all of these people that just start leaving the professions.
当我们开始在英国和美国进行那种里根-撒切尔式的问责革命时，变得更糟了。只是我们改变了目标，这样数字看起来我们更好，这样我们就不会失去资金，你知道，医院也是如此。所以，这在两个国家都发生了，因为人们开始花所有时间试图证明他们在做他们的工作，而不是真正做他们的工作。当你这样做时，你知道，生活方式的人力资源部门，你也失去了那些真正感到被召唤去做这件事的人，因为他们不再做这件事了。所以你有老师愿意接受每年3万美元的薪水，护士和所有这些开始离开职业的人。
And this is exactly what Porter predicted. When trust dies, you get mechanical objectivity. You can't trust the expert, so you replace the judgment with protocol. And America threw away, you know, all of these different interesting somatic and parts-based experiments in psychotherapy to pivot almost entirely to CBT as this assumption that it would replace everything. And DSM-3 and CBT were just kind of the future. And so, you know, we talked about David Rosenhan going into the hospital and getting himself committed as a psych patient. And then, you know, supposedly 10 of his students, too.
这正是波特所预测的。当信任死亡时，你得到机械的客观性。你不能信任专家，所以你用协议取代判断。美国抛弃了，你知道，所有这些在心理治疗中不同有趣的躯体和基于部分的实验，几乎完全转向CBT，作为一种它将取代一切的假设。DSM-3和CBT只是某种未来。所以，你知道，我们谈到了大卫·罗森汉（David Rosenhan）进入医院并让自己作为精神病人被收治。然后，你知道，据称他的10名学生也是。
And, you know, one of the things that that did was increase this insecurity in clinical psychology to where the DSM3 happens. You know, the Rosenhan experiment was one of the things that was the most public because he was one of theirs. He wasn't, you know, some guy writing a book saying, here's what you're doing to control society, man. Actual therapists started to speak up, especially in academic like Rosenhan. they were going to pay attention because they felt insecure and they didn't know how to answer. And so what we lost are the people like Jung and the post-Yungians from the mainstream of academia at that point who go on to make some of the most interesting modalities out there.
而且，你知道，那所做的事情之一就是增加了临床心理学中的这种不安全感，以至于DSM3发生了。你知道，罗森汉实验是最公开的事情之一，因为他是他们中的一员。他不是，你知道，某个写书说，这就是你们控制社会的方式，伙计的人。真正的治疗师开始大声疾呼，特别是在像罗森汉这样的学术界。他们会注意，因为他们感到不安全，他们不知道如何回答。所以我们失去的是像荣格和后荣格学派那样的人，从那时起学术界的主流，他们继续制作出一些最有趣的模式。
A lot of the best semantic and parts-based modalities are these sort of post-Yungian evolutions. And they didn't see archetypes as games. and so they leave the culture because they saw archetypes as patterns of meaning making that can connect an individual, you know, experience to human universal themes that make us feel part of a story, both the cultures and our own. And the hero's journey is a manipulation, you know, it's, or the hero's journey is not a manipulation. It's actually a map of what we're all trying to do.
许多最好的语义和基于部分的模态都是后荣格时代的演变。他们并不把原型视为游戏，因此他们离开了主流文化，因为他们将原型视为一种意义构建的模式，能够将个人的经历与人类普遍的主题联系起来，让我们感到自己是故事的一部分，无论是文化的故事还是我们自己的故事。英雄之旅是一种操纵，或者说，英雄之旅并非操纵，它实际上是我们所有人都在努力追求的目标的地图。
The games are when we get stuck in doing that, and their use is limited to analyzing our stuckness, not our purpose, but our stuckness pointing us away from our purpose, our inability to be effective. This is what drives price insane. You know, and when you have this culture losing that idea, when clinical psychology is losing that as a guiding map, it goes into the culture. I mean, you get Star Wars in the late 70s for this reason, which is just Joseph Campbell's hero's journey written by George Lucas. And you get the blockbuster, right? The people pushing for real change,
当我们陷入这种追求时，游戏就产生了，它们的用途仅限于分析我们的困境，而不是我们的目标，而是那些让我们偏离目标、无法发挥作用的困境。这就是让普莱斯发疯的原因。当这种文化失去了这一理念，当临床心理学失去了这一指导地图时，它就会渗透到文化中。我的意思是，70年代末出现的《星球大战》就是因为这个原因，它不过是乔治·卢卡斯编写的约瑟夫·坎贝尔的英雄之旅。你得到了大片，对吧？那些推动真正变革的人，
a ton of them go into storytelling and mythology and D&D, you know, the people who were the would-be psychologists of this era. And there's a relevant quote here. I think, you know, like Walter Benjamin, who's one of the Frankfurt school guys, he says that the masses want change. But when controlled,
其中很多人投身于讲故事、神话和龙与地下城游戏，你知道，那些本该成为这个时代心理学家的人。这里有一句相关的名言。我想，法兰克福学派的瓦尔特·本雅明说过，大众想要变革。但当受到控制时，
control happens, you know, he calls it fascism, but like when you, when you start to have this group who doesn't want there to be change, they're faced with this inevitability where what that group has to do, you know, the fascists or the people who don't want the masses to have more property, more power, more control, which is kind of what happens with psychology, because everyone demands that psychology include these things. And in their insecurity, they run further away from them, you know, with the DSM3 into the checklist model and the objective, stuff. And anyway, back to Benjamin. He says, you know, when, when, when they're not wanting to give you the thing that you want, which is material, which is, you know, more time off, more money, more stuff, a house, food, or something of better quality, what they will give you is the right to express yourself. And so when what you're going to do is see politics become aesthetic. it's not about this is what I'll do for you I'll give you paved roads I'll give you schools I'll give you health care I'll give you Medicaid for all when you can't do that when those aren't options we'll just give you expressions of
控制就会发生，他称之为法西斯主义，但当你开始拥有这样一个不希望发生变革的群体时，他们面临着这种必然性，即该群体必须做的事情，你知道，法西斯分子或那些不希望大众拥有更多财产、更多权力、更多控制权的人，这正是心理学所发生的事情，因为每个人都要求心理学包含这些东西。在他们的不安全感中，他们通过DSM-3（精神疾病诊断与统计手册第3版）转向清单模型和客观事物，从而进一步远离了这些。总之，回到本雅明的话题。他说，当他们不想给你你想要的东西时，也就是物质上的东西，比如更多的休假时间、更多的钱、更多的东西、房子、食物或质量更好的东西，他们会给你的权利是表达你自己。所以，当你看到政治变得审美化时，这不再是关于“我能为你做什么，我会给你铺路，我会给你学校，我会给你医疗保健，我会给你全民医疗补助”，当你做不到这些，当这些不是选项时，我们只会给你表达的机会。
cultural change you know the person with the identity that you don't like won't be represented in commercials they won't be represented in Congress they won't be represented here. And then that way you feel like you're expressing yourself because, you know, the person that you don't like is being alienated or othered in the culture and the person that you do like who represents you, who usually looks like you, is having the power. And so it's this sort of false freedom where people hear heard without really being helped because they feel like they're changing something without something really changing.
文化变革，你知道，你不喜欢的身份的人不会出现在广告中，他们不会出现在国会中，他们不会出现在这里。这样你就觉得自己在表达自己，因为你不喜欢的人在文化中被疏远或被排斥，而你喜欢的人，那个代表你的人，通常长得和你一样的人，正在掌握权力。所以这是一种虚假的自由，人们觉得被听到了，但并没有真正得到帮助，因为他们觉得自己在改变某些东西，而实际上什么都没有改变。
And a lot of those Frankfurt school guys are pretty similar in what they're doing because they're fusing Freud with somebody like Marx, you know, who says this thing's a struggle. It's a game. And a lot of that comes from Wilhelm Reich. You know, the Frankfurt school guys disavow him, but the Freudian and semantic psychology, that's where they got it in order to have those analyses of, you know, post-World War II culture, basically, where they're trying to figure out what's going on in the system. And so the dark. The dark, side of repressing all of that messy humanity is that it doesn't go away, it just comes back up as this monster. You know, if you ignore the shadows, then they return as demons, is what Jung said. And when you exhal something from consciousness, like in this point, our real purpose, our humanity, our ability to be subjective, to bring subjectivity into our lives, you know, it doesn't disappear. It just goes underground. And in the age, you know, right as we're rolling out this cold, rational, Nashian worldview, um, society went insane.
很多法兰克福学派的人所做的事情非常相似，因为他们将弗洛伊德与马克思这样的人融合在一起，马克思说这是一种斗争，是一个游戏。其中很多来自威廉·赖希。法兰克福学派的人否认他，但弗洛伊德和语义心理学是他们获得这些分析的来源，基本上是为了分析二战后的文化，试图弄清楚系统里发生了什么。所以，压抑所有那些混乱的人性的阴暗面是，它不会消失，它只是以怪物的形式卷土重来。荣格说过，如果你忽视阴影，它们就会以恶魔的形式回归。当你从意识中排斥某些东西时，比如在这一点上，我们真正的目的、我们的人性、我们主观的能力、将主观性带入生活的能力，它并不会消失，它只是转入地下。而在我们推出这种冷酷、理性的纳什式世界观的时代，社会疯了。
We had the satanic panic. People started to believe that there were literal demons and daycare centers and hundreds of them, satanic cults, you know, ritually abusing children and all of this stuff. And I think that a lot of that had to do with people realizing that they were being hurt and that culture was getting worse, but not really being able to see who to blame. because in the mainstream culture, they're being represented. Like my group's in control
我们经历了撒旦恐慌。人们开始相信日托中心里真的有恶魔，成百上千的撒旦邪教在仪式性地虐待儿童等等。我认为这很大程度上是因为人们意识到自己受到了伤害，文化正在恶化，但却无法看出该责怪谁。因为在主流文化中，他们被代表了。就像我的群体在掌控之中，
and we've reached the pinnacle of our aesthetic journey or agenda, but there's not any change in my life that is good. I feel bad. I feel worse. This is making me sick. And so why does any of this matter for mental health? Well, you know, millennials and Gen C
我们已经达到了审美旅程或议程的巅峰，但我的生活中没有任何好的改变。我感觉很糟糕。我感觉更糟了。这让我感到恶心。那么这一切对心理健康有什么影响呢？嗯，千禧一代和Z世代，
kind of inherited a lot of this trap. Like they're born into the world Nash's paranoia. and Burns vocabulary and Thatcher's policies and Beck's CBT, you know, those things have reached their zenith and are declining as millennials are coming up. And they live in this totally gamified environment where social media is a game and grades are a game and job applications are a game and dating apps are a game. And even their mental health vocabulary is gamified. Nervous system deregulation, attachment styles, trauma responses. Everything is a system to be optimized. And they're drowning because
某种程度上继承了这种陷阱。他们出生在纳什的偏执、伯恩的词汇、撒切尔的政策和贝克的CBT（认知行为疗法）的世界里，这些东西在千禧一代成长时达到了顶峰并开始衰落。他们生活在一个完全游戏化的环境中，社交媒体是游戏，成绩是游戏，求职申请是游戏，约会软件是游戏。甚至他们的心理健康词汇也是游戏化的。神经系统失调、依恋类型、创伤反应。一切都是需要优化的系统。他们正在淹没，因为
they're thinking about it like doing it right, not doing themselves or not doing it better or worse, but, you know, they're competing with everybody. And they have more access to therapy than any generation in history, but they're the most psychologically literate, you know, population ever. They know more about psychology by the time they're 12 just from movies if their parents didn't put them in therapy, which is much more likely to happen for that generation. You know, 42% of them attend therapy, 87% of them feel. comfortable discussing mental help.
他们考虑的是如何“做对”，而不是做自己，也不是做得更好或更差，而是与所有人竞争。他们比历史上任何一代人都有更多的治疗机会，但他们也是有史以来心理学素养最高的人群。如果他们的父母没有让他们接受治疗（这对那一代人来说更有可能发生），他们到12岁时通过电影了解的心理学知识就比以前多得多。你知道，他们中有42%的人参加过治疗，87%的人觉得讨论心理健康很自在。
Giant change there from the boomers. And it's not helping. Rates of anxiety and depression and self-harm and suicidal ideation keep climbing. And this is the treatment prevalence paradox. More therapy has not produced less suffering. And a lot of that is, yes, probably because the world is getting worse around us, around the experiment that you're trying to run with time. But the words are the wrong words.
与婴儿潮一代相比发生了巨大的变化。但这并没有帮助。焦虑、抑郁、自残和自杀意念的比率持续攀升。这就是治疗普及悖论。更多的治疗并没有减少痛苦。这很大程度上是因为，是的，可能因为我们周围的世界正在变得更糟，围绕着你试图用时间进行的实验。但这些词用错了。
The frame is the wrong frame. They're being offered debugging for their souls. and they're being given worksheets when they need witnessing, and they're being measured when they need to be met, and increasingly they're rejecting that. As a culture, it's being reflected in attitudes about mental health as the most comfortable in generation to ever encounter it as it starts to encounter it.
框架用错了。他们被提供的是灵魂的调试，当他们需要见证时，他们得到的是工作表；当他们需要被遇见时，他们得到的是被测量；他们越来越拒绝这种方式。作为一个文化，这反映在对心理健康的态度上，作为有史以来最舒适的一代，当它开始接触心理健康时。
They have distrust and negative experiences, and they need what the game framework can't provide. They need meaning, they need connection, they need presence, and they need purpose. And they need to know that they're not, machines and that their suffering isn't a bug to be debugged, that they're longing for something real is not naive, and they also need to know that it's okay to feel like the world is broken, because a lot of them feel like they're not allowed to say that. And they need to know that
他们有不信任和负面经历，他们需要游戏框架无法提供的东西。他们需要意义，需要联系，需要存在感，需要目标。他们需要知道他们不是机器，他们的痛苦不是需要调试的错误，他们对真实事物的渴望不是天真，他们还需要知道觉得世界破碎了是可以的，因为他们很多人觉得他们不被允许说出来。他们需要知道，
George Price is wrong. Love is not just this equation, that there's an exit to that trap, which is big, heady stuff. You know, this is a lot less technical and almost more philosophical or spiritual than the talking about the way the DSM got where it was. But to me, they're related. You know, they're part of the same problem of how do we anticipate and fix like a better therapy. So what is the exit to the trap? You know, Curtis is pretty pessimistic.
乔治·普莱斯错了。爱不仅仅是一个等式，那个陷阱是有出口的，这可是宏大而深奥的东西。这比讨论DSM是如何走到今天这一步要少一些技术性，而更多是哲学或精神层面的。但对我来说，它们是相关的。它们是同一个问题的一部分，即我们如何预测和修复更好的治疗方法。那么陷阱的出口是什么？柯蒂斯相当悲观。
He says, as documentary ends with the suggestion that we're just kind of stuck in the self-fulfilling prophecy and it's run so long, we can't remember anything else so we don't know that we're playing a game. And I'm slightly more hopeful, not because I think the systems will change easily. they won't, but because the trap only works if you believe it. And here's the trick that you can do at the end of this episode. You don't have to think about yourself this way. And when you notice a part of yourself is thinking about this way, you can realize that
他说，纪录片以一种暗示结束，即我们只是陷入了自我实现的预言，而且它运行了太久，我们记不起其他任何事情，所以我们不知道我们正在玩一个游戏。我稍微乐观一点，不是因为我认为系统会轻易改变，它们不会，而是因为陷阱只有在你相信它时才有效。这是你在本集结束时可以做的技巧。你不必这样看待自己。当你注意到自己的一部分在这样思考时，你可以意识到，
it's just a part, that is sad and afraid. And it has a purpose. It's trying to protect you from being taken advantage of and being hurt again. And when you realize, and your job is not to get rid of it, it's to know that when you need it, it's there. And when you don't, you can put it down. and you can recognize this gamified thing of like one more one more one more and say do i need this part of me right now and if you don't need it you put it down in a way that doesn't threaten it doesn't upset it
那只是一个悲伤和恐惧的部分。它有一个目的。它试图保护你不被利用，不再次受到伤害。当你意识到这一点时，你的工作不是摆脱它，而是知道当你需要它时它就在那里。当你不需要它时，你可以放下它。你可以识别这种“再来一次，再来一次”的游戏化事物，并问自己：我现在需要我这一部分吗？如果你不需要，你就以一种不会威胁到它、不会让它不安的方式放下它。
it's just there when you need it again when you realize i may not trust this person i need to run some angles there but it isn't the point of your existence it's just a part of you that is there for good reason that you can love and have a good relationship with and you can love and have a good relationship with You know, once you start to see these assumptions and notice that they're there, you can question them. And yeah, people play games. People also love and people also sacrifice and people also create and people also connect, not as strategies and not as moves in a bigger game,
当你再次需要它时，它就在那里，当你意识到“我可能不信任这个人，我需要耍点手段”时，它就在那里，但它不是你存在的意义，它只是你的一部分，它存在是有充分理由的，你可以爱它并与它保持良好的关系。一旦你开始看到这些假设并注意到它们的存在，你就可以质疑它们。是的，人们玩游戏。人们也爱，人们也牺牲，人们也创造，人们也联系，不是作为策略，也不是作为更大游戏中的棋子，
but as expressions of something that exists before strategy. And the mother gazing at an infant, when my wife looked at my daughter, she wasn't calculating a payoff. When I looked at my daughter for the first time, I was not calculating a payoff. I mean, the friend who sits with you in your grief isn't seeking strokes. They're present. And the therapist who holds space for your pain is not gamifying their relationship.
而是作为某种先于策略存在的事物的表达。母亲凝视婴儿时，当我的妻子看着我的女儿时，她并没有在计算回报。当我第一次看着我的女儿时，我也没有在计算回报。我的意思是，在你悲伤时陪伴你的朋友并不是在寻求安慰。他们只是在场。而为你痛苦留出空间的治疗师并没有将他们的关系游戏化。
They're witnessing. You know, these things are real and they happen all the time. And the game frame can't see them because it has no categories for them. And to an increasing extent, our culture and our medical system and some of the rules that govern therapy can no longer see them, but that doesn't make them not real. and that doesn't make you not crazy for seeing or for longing for those things. But that's a limitation of the framework. It's not a limitation of reality.
他们在见证。这些事情是真实的，它们一直都在发生。游戏框架看不到它们，因为它没有分类。在很大程度上，我们的文化、我们的医疗系统以及一些管理治疗的规则已经无法看到它们，但这并不意味着它们不真实，也不意味着你因为看到或渴望这些东西而疯了。这是框架的局限性，而不是现实的局限性。
And it doesn't change who you are because you were told to think that way. Even if you weren't told with words, even if you weren't told directly. If you were told to think that way, it doesn't mean that that's who you are. And this is where I need to say something that may sound kind of contradictory. But I'm really skeptical of the idea that therapy is just self-expression or that TikTok and support groups could replace professional treatment or that it's just all relational. You just sit with somebody in a room, Rogerian, and eventually you being nice to them makes them better.
这并不会因为你被告知要那样思考而改变你是谁。即使你不是用语言被告知的，即使你不是直接被告知的。如果你被告知要那样思考，并不意味着那就是你。在这里，我需要说一些听起来有点矛盾的话。但我非常怀疑“治疗只是自我表达”或者“TikTok和支持小组可以取代专业治疗”或者“一切都是关系性的”这种观点。你只是坐在房间里和某人在一起，罗杰斯式的，最终你对他们好就能让他们好起来。
And I'm skeptical of these critiques where they're like, the whole system is just a corrupted systemic control anyway. I mean, I'm kind of making an argument that it is, but I'm also making an argument that it wasn't a whole lot of people who knew what they were doing or were sitting in a room smoking cigarettes and are the alumni that run the world. this is multiple things across history that culminated in the moment that we are in, and there will be many more to undo this. It wasn't one person that had all the power.
我怀疑这些批评，他们说“整个系统无论如何都只是腐败的系统性控制”。我的意思是，我正在论证它确实如此，但我也在论证，并不是一大群人知道自己在做什么，或者坐在房间里抽烟，然后成为了统治世界的校友。这是历史上多种因素的叠加，最终导致了我们所处的时刻，未来还会有更多因素来扭转这一点。并不是一个人拥有所有的权力。
It was a system of systems that started to give too much power to too few people. And, you know, the people that just say, well, yeah, your article's fine about the DSM, but it's really just the Sackler's running, you know, opiates or the Pfizer wants to sell pharmaceutical drugs, so they invent these diagnoses. Those systems aren't connected in this way. This is the way they're connected in, you know, in some ways it's a lot more nefarious and in some ways it's a lot more innocent. You know, and I understand the appeal of those kind of monadic narratives that put all of the oneness of control on one group of people because they're simple
这是一个系统之系统，开始给太少的人太多的权力。那些只说“好吧，你的关于DSM的文章很好，但实际上只是萨克勒家族在经营阿片类药物，或者辉瑞公司想卖药，所以他们发明了这些诊断”的人，这些系统并不是以这种方式连接的。它们连接的方式在某些方面更邪恶，在某些方面更无辜。我理解那些将控制权归咎于一个群体的单一叙事的吸引力，因为它们简单，
and easy to understand and they let you direct your rage somewhere quickly. But after everything that I've just told you about this trap, you know, Nash is paranoid. Nash is not a bad guy. You know, the Sherman Act that's not a bad bill. You know, the RUC, the is set up to solve a problem that is real with Medicaid billing creeping up from, you know, doctors over billing so that their rates are based on what the old metric was. You know, Aaron Beck, who's not a bad guy that invents CBT, you know, those systems were not made by bad people, but they still all conspired to turn the soul into software, which is not an evidence-based or scientific belief. And it makes sense to want to burn the whole thing down
容易理解，让你能迅速将愤怒指向某个地方。但在我告诉你关于这个陷阱的一切之后，纳什的偏执，纳什不是坏人。谢尔曼法案不是坏法案。RUC（相对价值更新委员会）的设立是为了解决一个真实的问题，即医疗补助账单因医生过度收费而不断攀升，导致他们的费率基于旧的指标。亚伦·贝克，发明CBT的也不是坏人，这些系统不是坏人制造的，但它们仍然合谋将灵魂变成了软件，这不是一种基于证据或科学的信仰。想要烧毁这一切并重新开始是有道理的。
and start over. And so I hear the anger, you know, when I hear from people, you know, people, but here's the thing. The corruption goes deeper than capitalism. It goes deeper than big pharma. It goes deeper than the RUC and insurance companies. It's invaded yours assumptions, yours and mine. And the way that you think about health, the way that you think about self, the way that you imagine what healing even means, that's been colonized too. The trap isn't just in the institutions. It's in your imagination. And here's what the trap does. It strips you of creativity and the imagination to envision a better world. It makes you think that only, options, your only options are a corrupt system or do it yourself. And it forecloses this
所以我听到了愤怒，当我听到人们这么说时。但问题是，腐败比资本主义更深。它比大型制药公司更深。它比RUC和保险公司更深。它侵入了你的假设，你和我的。你思考健康的方式，你思考自我的方式，你想象治愈意味着什么的方式，这些也都被殖民了。陷阱不仅在机构中。它在你的想象力中。陷阱的作用是：它剥夺了你的创造力和想象一个更美好世界的能力。它让你认为你唯一的选择是腐败的系统或自己动手。它排除了这种
possibility that care could be a right, that institutions could serve human flourishing, that expertise could be trustworthy, that systems of control aren't as easy as saying, well, capitalism corrupts everything, so let's opt out. It's not just psychopharmaceutical companies paying for studies or the Sackler's pushing opioids. It goes deeper than that. It's the way that this thing has invaded your own assumptions and it stripped you of creativity and imagination to envision a better world. When you just say, hey, I don't like the way these things work. When we look at how they work and why they got there, they don't really look like good things. And somebody just attacks you and says, that's crazy. This is a conspiracy theory. That's wrong. It's because just the idea of saying,
可能性：护理可以是一种权利，机构可以服务于人类的繁荣，专业知识可以是值得信赖的，控制系统并不像说“资本主义腐败了一切，所以让我们退出”那么简单。这不仅仅是心理制药公司支付研究费用或萨克勒家族推销阿片类药物。它比这更深。这是这种东西侵入你自身假设的方式，它剥夺了你的创造力和想象一个更美好世界的能力。当你只是说“嘿，我不喜欢这些东西的运作方式”时。当我们审视它们是如何运作以及为什么会走到这一步时，它们看起来并不像好东西。而有人攻击你说“这很疯狂，这是阴谋论，那是错的”。这是因为仅仅是说，
hey, we can have a slightly better world than the one that we're in right now has become so scary to that person, that you feel like a threat. And the people who say, yeah, just use herbs or go find your, you know, do a drum circle in a support group or clean your room or something. I mean, those are fine if they work, but you're kind of being glib about how seriously traumatized our culture is, how bad it needs therapy, and also the realities of trauma that can just be really awful. And don't go away if you clean up your room or you take like Hornet Venom from Joe Rogan or something. they're offering, you know, this empowerment that you have power over this because it's in you. You just got to find it within yourself.
“嘿，我们可以拥有一个比现在稍微好一点的世界”这个想法对那个人来说变得如此可怕，以至于你感觉像是一个威胁。那些说“是的，只用草药，或者去找你的支持小组跳个鼓圈，或者打扫你的房间”的人，如果这些方法有效，那很好，但你对我们的文化受到的创伤有多严重、它有多需要治疗，以及创伤的现实有多糟糕，表现得太轻率了。如果你打扫房间或者从乔·罗根那里拿什么大黄蜂毒液之类的东西，这些创伤是不会消失的。他们提供这种赋权，说你对此有权力，因为它在你体内。你只需要在自己内心找到它。
But we can't survive like that. You know, it feels good. It feels liberating. It feels like you're escaping this trap. But it's this false empowerment because when things get really bad, the suicidal ideation doesn't respond to journaling. When the panic attacks don't go away when you do breathwork or getting an ice bath. And when psychosis starts happening and you need medication, you need a real doctor. And you're going to want someone who went to school who got super.
但我们不能那样生存。这感觉很好。这感觉很解放。这感觉就像你在逃离这个陷阱。但这是虚假的赋权，因为当事情变得非常糟糕时，自杀意念不会对写日记做出反应。当恐慌发作时，做呼吸练习或洗冰水澡并不能让它们消失。当精神病开始发生，你需要药物时，你需要一个真正的医生。你会想要一个上过学、受过专业训练的人，
who is vetted by a board who understands the difference between a trauma response and a thyroid problem and who knows when medication is necessary and when it's not and who has seen a thousand cases and can recognize what you can't see for yourself and that doesn't mean that everybody who went to school and went got certified by a board is good it means that you're going to need somebody who's done that and is and yeah the system doesn't do a great job of screening there's bad therapists there's corrupt psychiatrists. There's pill mills, you know, pretending to be treatment centers and like, yes, there's sacklers and profit.
一个经过委员会审查的人，一个了解创伤反应和甲状腺问题之间区别的人，一个知道什么时候需要药物、什么时候不需要的人，一个见过一千个病例、能识别你自己看不到的东西的人。这并不意味着所有上过学、获得委员会认证的人都是好的，这意味着你需要一个做过这些事情的人。是的，系统的筛选工作做得并不好，有糟糕的治疗师，有腐败的精神科医生。有假装成治疗中心的药丸工厂，是的，有萨克勒家族和利润。
And yes, the boards have lots of problems. And the training is not adequate. You know, I make a case for on here. And the incentives are also broken. I make a loud case for. I have issues with all that stuff and I think they should be better. But the people who do understand trauma, who do good work, who I talk to every day, you know, across the world. I don't talk to somebody around the world every day,
是的，委员会有很多问题。培训也不足。我在这里提出了一个案例。激励机制也坏了。我大声疾呼。我对所有这些事情都有意见，我认为它们应该更好。但那些真正了解创伤、做着好工作的人，我每天都在和他们交谈，在世界各地。我不是每天都和世界各地的人交谈，
but I talk to people very frequently because of this show and my blog from all over the world and all over America that are doing great work and went to school and got licensed and they submit to board oversight, not because the system's perfect, but because the alternative is a world where anyone can claim to be a healer with no accountability
但我因为这个节目和我的博客，非常频繁地与来自世界各地和美国各地的人交谈，他们正在做伟大的工作，他们上过学，获得了执照，他们服从委员会的监督，不是因为系统是完美的，而是因为替代方案是一个任何人都可以声称自己是治疗师而无需承担任何责任的世界，
and that's not going well. And so even though I have a problem with the way that some of the regulation is implemented, I still think that you need something real, not just aesthetics, not just this pseudo power of you can just do everything yourself and you don't really need experts for anything. And you also don't really need, you know, material things like medicine. Because you can just do it yourself. I think that that is people who have absorbed this game to their core and are wholly captured. And the answer to corrupt institutions is not no institutions
那情况并不好。所以即使我对某些监管的实施方式有意见，我仍然认为你需要真实的东西，不仅仅是审美，不仅仅是“你可以自己做所有事情，你不需要专家”这种伪权力。你也不需要像药物这样的物质东西。因为你可以自己做。我认为那是那些已经将这个游戏吸收进骨子里并完全被俘虏的人。对腐败机构的回答不是没有机构，
as better institutions. I mean, the answer to captured credentialing isn't no credentialing. It's credentialing that serves its purpose. If you get elected and then as somebody who runs the government, you say the government's bad, well, that's kind of your fault at this point, dog. Like, you're the one who has the power to change the way that all of these things work. They aren't inherently bad. Nothing is.
而是更好的机构。我的意思是，对被俘获的认证的回答不是没有认证。而是服务于其目的的认证。如果你当选了，然后作为政府的管理者，你说政府很糟糕，好吧，那在这一点上是你自己的错。你是那个有权力改变所有这些运作方式的人。它们并非天生就是坏的。没有什么东西是天生坏的。
If you're in charge and you're saying it's bad, you're just saying that you're doing a bad job. You know, the answer to a health care system that treats people like machines is not abandoning health care. It's fighting health care that treats, it's fighting full. or health care that treats people like people. Care is a right. It's not a privilege. You know, it's not a product. It's not something that you earn by being productive or having good insurance.
如果你负责，而你说它很糟糕，你只是在说你工作做得不好。你知道，对把人当作机器对待的医疗保健系统的回答不是放弃医疗保健。而是对抗那种把人当作人来对待的医疗保健。护理是一种权利。它不是特权。它不是产品。它不是你通过提高生产力或拥有好的保险而赚来的东西。
It's a right. And rights require institutions to guarantee them. They require professionals trained to provide them. They require systems that can be held accountable when they fail. And the do-it-yourself critique leaves all of that out. The do-it-alone critique leaves all of that out. It takes the real insight or the abandon-the-system altogether critique. and go into the woods and use a crystal do that because it feels good please don't do that to cure your cancer
它是一种权利。权利需要机构来保障。它们需要受过培训的专业人员来提供。它们需要当失败时可以被追究责任的系统。而“自己动手”的批评忽略了所有这些。独自一人的批评忽略了所有这些。它采取了真正的洞察力，或者“完全放弃系统”的批评，去森林里用一块水晶，请不要为了治愈癌症而这样做，
you know it takes the real insight that the system is broken and draws the wrong conclusion but we shouldn't abandon the system entirely that's not freedom either that's atomization and that's the final victory of nash's worldview where we're all isolated individuals who are in competition to see who gets the highest score you know before they die i guess maybe there should be a little bit more arc and a little bit more of a process to this thing that we call life where we accept some limitations on it that we do age that we do die that we have a limited amount of time to kind of go inward and understand how we think and to learn how to act effectively and to put down the games that we don't want and then learn how to play a new game you know i refuse to give up hope for
你知道，它采取了系统崩溃的真正洞察力，但得出了错误的结论。我们不应该完全放弃系统，那也不是自由，那是原子化，那是纳什世界观的最终胜利，我们都是孤立的个体，在竞争看谁在死前得分最高。我想也许我们应该多一点弧度，多一点我们称之为生活的过程，我们接受它的一些局限性，我们确实会变老，我们确实会死亡，我们有有限的时间去向内看，去理解我们是如何思考的，去学习如何有效地行动，去放下我们不想要的游戏，然后学习如何玩一个新的游戏。你知道，我拒绝放弃希望，
this thing i refuse it while i also refuse to pretend that the current system is working and that's hard a lot of people say it's got to be this binary choice between, well, if there's two different theories in the field and there's two different directions, which one's the good one? I'm saying neither. But I'm adult enough to realize that just because nobody is going in the right direction doesn't mean that I'm so scared I have to back the candidate in the least bad one. You know, I don't have to pick between what the DSM-5 did and, you know, the R-Doc that's stripping everything down to a biomarker,
我拒绝。同时我也拒绝假装当前的系统正在运作，这很难。很多人说这必须是一个二元选择，如果领域里有两种不同的理论，有两个不同的方向，哪一个是好的？我说都不是。但我足够成熟，意识到仅仅因为没有人走在正确的方向上，并不意味着我害怕到必须支持最不坏的那个候选人。你知道，我不必在DSM-5所做的和NIMH正在做的将一切简化为生物标志物的R-Doc之间做出选择，
that the NIMH is doing. I got things accusing me in the first one of picking a side between those. I think that they're both bad. I think something like Hightop that cluster symptoms is the way that you actually make the science fit the story. Not the, you actually make the story fit the science, not just kind of adjust the science to try and fit the story that you want to tell. But too much of this has changed human nature
有人指责我在第一个问题上选边站。我认为它们都很糟糕。我认为像HiTOP（分层分类法）那样聚类症状是让科学真正符合故事的方式。不是你让故事符合科学，不仅仅是调整科学来试图符合你想讲的故事。但太多这些东西已经改变了人性，
as we've imbibed these passive assumptions about ourselves. But the system's, needs to be radically transformed and the system is still the best framework that we have for delivering care and the people doing good work are working within it not outside of it and the goal is to make the system worthy of people to serve within it this is not anti-science it's an argument for a better science you know nash gave us this paranoid math burn gave us the cultural vocabulary and porter explained why trust died but neoliberalism gave us this political implementation And we became the creatures the model described because the system left us no other language with which to view ourselves.
因为我们吸收了这些关于我们自己的被动假设。但系统需要被彻底改造，而系统仍然是我们提供护理的最佳框架，做着好工作的人是在系统内工作，而不是在系统外，目标是让系统值得人们在其中服务。这不是反科学，这是对更好科学的论证。纳什给了我们这种偏执的数学，伯恩给了我们文化词汇，波特解释了信任为何死亡，但新自由主义给了我们这种政治实施。我们变成了模型所描述的生物，因为系统没有给我们其他语言来审视自己。
But the models are wrong from the beginning. They were projections of a paranoid mind onto the human condition and they were assumptions disguised as discoveries. Nash told everyone that himself. And the proof that they were wrong is that we are still here, still longing for connections, still aching for meaning, still capable of love that is not calculation. And George Price couldn't find that exit. You know, he bled out trying to disprove his own math because he needed therapy. He thought by imbibing this model to its root, he thought that life was not worth living
但模型从一开始就是错的。它们是偏执心灵对人类状况的投射，它们是伪装成发现的假设。纳什自己告诉了所有人。它们是错的证明是，我们仍然在这里，仍然渴望联系，仍然渴望意义，仍然有能力进行非计算的爱。乔治·普莱斯找不到那个出口。他试图推翻自己的数学而流血致死，因为他需要治疗。他认为通过将这个模型吸收到底层，他认为生活不值得活，
because he couldn't see another way to understand himself in the world. And that's the reason why I put something this dark in a podcast is because I feel like too many people have imbibed this system and have seen their, they are using it to understand their relationship to the world in a way that is driving them mad. You know, it's not about math or what the math meant. Love is not refuted by being explicable. Kindness is not negated by having origins. Connection is not fake because you can trace its biology. A trap is real, but it's not the whole story. The trap says you're a machine, but you're not. And the trap told us, us that meaning was naive and unsurious.
因为他看不到另一种理解自己和世界的方式。这就是为什么我把这么黑暗的东西放在播客里的原因，因为我觉得太多人吸收了这个系统，并用它来理解他们与世界的关系，这正在让他们发疯。这与数学或数学意味着什么无关。爱不会因为可解释而被反驳。善良不会因为有起源而被否定。联系不会因为你可以追踪其生物学而变得虚假。陷阱是真实的，但它不是全部。陷阱说你是机器，但你不是。陷阱告诉我们，意义是天真和无用的。
It's not. It's the purpose. And when we can remember the trap we're in, when we can see it, then we can figure out how to get out. But the first step is being able to see the world you're in. And to a large extent, I hope to cover this in the next one, I think Gen Z is already demanding that. I don't think it's optional.
它不是。它是目的。当我们能记住我们所处的陷阱时，当我们能看到它时，我们就能弄清楚如何走出去。但第一步是能够看到你所处的世界。在很大程度上，我希望在下一集中涵盖这一点，我认为Z世代已经在要求这一点了。我不认为这是可选的。
You know, I'm telling therapists this because I want this profession to change. And I think that the next generation is telling us that it has to. I'm telling the profession this because like I point out to people when I do use Eric Byrne in the room to anticipate how things even wellness might impact their family might create a new game. You know, two people in the adult ego state cannot play a game. It's somebody in a child ego state and a parentified ego state. And the children are telling us at this point, that they want a new model of therapy, that this thing does not work for them.
你知道，我告诉治疗师这些，是因为我希望这个职业改变。我认为下一代正在告诉我们它必须改变。我告诉这个行业这些，因为就像我向人们指出的那样，当我确实在房间里使用埃里克·伯恩的理论来预测事物，甚至健康可能会如何影响他们的家庭，可能会创造一个新的游戏。你知道，处于成人自我状态的两个人不能玩游戏。那是处于儿童自我状态和家长式自我状态的人。而孩子们在这一点上正在告诉我们，他们想要一种新的治疗模式，这种东西对他们不起作用。
They're telling us that on TikTok. They're telling us that in these Reddit groups. They're telling us that when we survey them, you know, with pupils. And so what we have to realize is that the game has already been broken by the next generation. It's up to us how to figure out to play the next game. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们在TikTok上告诉我们。他们在这些Reddit群组里告诉我们。当我们在调查他们时，他们告诉我们。所以我们必须意识到，游戏已经被下一代打破了。如何弄清楚玩下一个游戏取决于我们。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。